the strongest chess world came to
Santlu from take part in the first cube
Earns pleased the participants in the first round
fans spectacular and uncompromising
four games out of five ended in the game
successful ex-world champion
Russian Alexandra Kosteniuk beat
black representative of Germany
Elizabeth Pats Russian Valentina Gunina
defeated Bella Khatinashvili from Georgia
the youngest participant in the tournament Zhansaya
Abdumalik from Kazakhstan started the tournament with
victory for this Zatonsky American
chess player Irina crash beat
Georgian
[music]
Good afternoon dear friends
welcome sunloys Anastasia Karlovich and
Elmira Skripchenko Good afternoon we will be
make you happy today
comments Today the second begins
can's cup tour and 10 participants will start
in the fight in 10 minutes and of course
I would like to remind you that in the first round
there were a lot of successful games
that is, 4 5 out of 5 are over
the results are simply stunning
result and we forgot that you
wanted to joke a little
broke the local public and the public all over
the world's only draw
so I hope it's all five today
games will end successfully
It's possible to believe there was only one draw
draw This is women's chess
spectacular
board and in 10 minutes the second one will start
tour today with us
a very interesting meeting is planned
I think we should talk first
about what it's like now what it's like now
standings
[music]
Nothing since yesterday
still four members have changed
those who won the game scored one point each
in the first round it is Alexandra Kosteniuk
Valentina Gunina Zhansaya Abdumalik Irina
crash on the shelf at harike, they tore at
Marie completely unexpected results
for this tournament we emphasize once again
a Next goes on over the zagnidze Elizabeth
our Willie and she Zatonsky who have
currently zero points but everything is ahead
and just the tournament is so strong that
Again, I would like to repeat that any
participant capable of winning and retains
chances
getting zero in the first round it can
of course to offend provoke anger
I really wanted to see
How did the participants prepare for the next one?
the parties were changed or they were a little
debut preparation actually come on
Let's also remind viewers about the format of the tournament
Let's
summary of previous episodes
we have 10 players who play
the round robin system gives 90 per game
minutes for the first 40 moves then 30 minutes
until the end of the game and also after each
progress is added another 30 seconds yes This is
standard control of all competitions
feed that is
classic control and I think it's necessary
also remind you that
the participant has no right to offer
draw before move 30 with black of some kind
logical
some logical part of the party
still needs to be completed first
than rivals can offer a draw but
basically I think that in this tournament
We are not particularly threatened by this in reality
Except for one game that ended
only later in the endgame, basically everything
decided in the last minutes
chess game we saw that
practically
all games from yesterday's round
ended with a color note because
literally already on the 15-20th move it’s almost like
everyone had 15-20 minutes left and
they solved a lot of opening problems
and problems go spiers that is wrong
We just wanted to let you know once again what we have
there are 9 rounds in this competition and
The tournament will last on February 6th and
will last until February 15 if we don’t have
there will be a tiebreaker
the broadcast will start every day
at 12:50 local time which is about 10
hours Moscow time
and now we would also like to talk about
prize fund This is a very important point
this is actually a very important point
because
Women's chess still attracts everyone
more attention
sponsors
it is very nice
total prize fund for this tournament
is 150 thousand dollars
first prize 40 thousand dollars further
descending 30 thousand 20 thousand
last prize for 10th place participant
will receive 5000
in fact it seems to me that this is
a very impressive prize fund and If
compare other tournaments that I
I think that even Elmirates are even better with
familiar with this
Do you remember very well the numbers that were 15
years ago 20 years ago I can name
only those that exist on
today is acceptable if on your
world championship then first prize in
World Championship 60 thousand dollars if
remember the World Cup which is very
sizes that pass by knockout
system which ended in
Khanty-Mansiysk first suggested 60
thousand and the second 30 is already there
the fall is pretty fast I think
these are very good prizes and I think everyone
the participant will be even more
motivated to show interesting stuff here
game and compete for the highest places
Well, of course, in principle, in chess we
we observe
These are completely natural changes.
Well, it’s like a reward for chess players
firstly, sport is becoming more and more
more professional and compared
with other sports something like
the phenomenon would be observed in tennis and in
other sports disciplines where
the athletes not only showed very
good game but they got interested and
companies sponsors who invested
money for the development of sports That is me
I hope there are tournaments like this in chess
Hmm they will put very
good tradition and in principle
there should be super tournaments in my opinion
the opinion of especially women is much greater
everything will be so And now we move on to
life of the second round
Not
first
that two chess games are practically not
met the only one
they played the game of Europeans
in 2017 which
the youngest participant in this tournament
so it's absolutely nothing
there is nothing unusual in this and it seems to me
it will be very, very interesting
party Next comes Alexandra Kasinnik
against Anna Zatonskikh right here
I don't think we've met more than once in chess
in fact they played a lot
parties that surprised me when I
basically looked through their statistics
meetings that are actually in
she leads the Zatonsky classical parties
three and a half on the floor That is, she
very, very inconvenient opponent for
Alexandra Kostyunyuk and it would even be
I'm interested to see how
Alexander prepared uh for this
party Did she find any option
which surprised Anna she is very persistent
chess player
his resistance is very high
maybe it's also like uh like this
factor that slightly destabilizes
Alexandru
leads 2.0 increased meetings
That is, she plus 2 lies, let’s say
there was a lot
Elizabeth has not yet succeeded
was to beat
Kharko was spoiled, it must be rotten
yes actually yes they played too
they played a lot of games
many classical parts and
the classics were usually always won by whites
That is, it is very interesting for us too
left Central Central Party
Darina Krush vs Valentina Gunina
of course both are leaders in tournaments
one point and they played among themselves
only in blitz
absolutely therefore much very
it will be interesting to see how
complete everyone's first meeting
classic chess like this
confrontation of styles I think Irina Krush
which is a very classic style
positional she is a very positional group
correct very correct chess
trying to understand
all the nuances of the depth of Valentin’s position
just a sorceress on a chess board
the blackboard is always trying
looked up Probably lighting for me
or it seems to me that this might come in handy
lighting in principle for chess players
in principle it is very important not even worth it
forget the precedent that is the party when
Bobbie Fish insisted on good things
coverage in the match with Boris Spassky well
let's say this is one of the requirements
But in fact, not as if not the most
irrational because it is very
important And sometimes in poor lighting it is very
your eyes hurt a lot and you lose
concentration is just absolutely that is
for me it is completely logical and to be
maybe there is either a problem with the fan I
I don't know what's really going on
you have to look at the chessboard
sometimes 6 hours 5-6 hours and if
The lighting is bad, it's very unpleasant
or more And in fact even
there are standards of what should be
What should the lighting be like?
You see Irina
knight's descent at 3 which leads to
positional struggle
I don't know if she put her choice on
side of the disk at the beginning or it will translate
I don't know he's coming
retains
the right to choose opening schemes You can
convert to Catalan
g34 play it all depends on
Valentina Valentina In my memory
in my opinion he doesn’t play Strandian defense
or very rarely You see most likely
Irina may transfer the game from
transit beginning but I don’t know again
it depends on Valentina whether she chooses
the circuit with T6 is already 4, this is what I have by the way
played before a little familiar here
the idea in these positions is actually and in
whites have a very wide choice of blacks
depends
where will black place his bishop? But they
in principle they can even leave it
scheme
at five
plays schemes
similar to Miran that is
D7
I don’t know if Ira intended to play this
scheme with a pawn on D3 from literally up to 4
moving the pawn generally all four B3 then
this debut is actually interesting
because
aka 4 I play it for you and
spent a lot of time
studies schematics from service 4
I'm interested in Irina played we see
on the screen she played two zeros here again
also reserving the right to choose
blacks can go here
and knight D7 comes
because very often
[music]
you can then make it difficult for yourself to develop
Ira most likely chose D3 then
probably a scheme for three years two Queen E1
E4 yes then this is already a scheme for more countries
Indian beginning
[music]
I remember complaining about it all together.
with Zhenya when they commented here And
now I hear it, our neighbors are noisy
I'll have to complain about them
and here again it’s as if the blacks are thinking
will they decide on the knight on F6 then at
plan 2e4
very often taken before meals will be E5 already
Then
go straight away or if you want
[music]
I don't know how to keep it either
opportunity
and again the whites retained
the opportunity to play C4 in this position then
it leads to completely different structures
184 then Black will already go I'm 6 newbie
Ira went knight D2 and then she was already faster
will translate the game in total
positional channel and 6
here you can go straight away 4 you can go
sometimes I think it takes as many as three and
asks where this elephant will go I don’t
I know at this moment or later
sometimes I feel like I don't really know
scheme C4 is profitable not to go as many as three to
I don’t know sometimes to save some ideas
for 4 kuni 5 but again in this position
it all looks quite abstract
But
despite this, these positions may be
very specific therefore the most
nuances were seen yesterday in Italian
let's go, that is, there could be as many as three here too
could be a profitable move Or could it be
not at all, that is
If black if white go C4 what
I'll be very surprised then of course
you can put the bishop on d6 and again
with the idea then after castling Rook 8
carry out E5 with E4 with plan with
Of course, it’s better not to install E46 then
it’s already black usually, but let’s say let’s
we'll just show you
if White goes E4
I think it's very possible
and go sun 5
and than
Well, somehow it’s completely normal
this is a sample and I like it for Blacks
I also think since you played for the whites
So you must have liked her
because of white A And in fact it is a loss
a pace that seems like she's spending six
she's five at two paces, she's not like that
important thing here you should always keep an eye on
plans later with some related
you'll bend four horses to five, that's very
White often plays too, as many as three of course
four Hmm but they also have problems with
development of this position not so not so
obviously that is why the queens are leaving
one we actually release
Well, it’s just why we go, it’s not only
to untie but also to
release the knight with D2 We still defend
pawn just E4 and let him jump
on C4
bring out the elephant sometimes walk B3 B3 walk
black again
it turns out such a long positional
maneuver fighting
[music]
he did not decide
Then most likely she can
decided on a plan Already three suns 5 of course
4 there is such an idea with F4
Yes, and there are 7 F4 for an elephant, like this
I have some idea and I think I even have it
analyzed
now she's threatening She's actually 45
very interesting positions arise white
they also move even queen 1 then carry out
E4 Well, in general, it’s always strange with the idea
of course, well, Ira, you see, she went all the way
3-4 That is, she moved the position into the direction
from the transient beginning itself
almost classic Well already with
the elephant is already four five
I think that
can you just go
Karakan also plays with black and
she has already brought out the bishop and these positions
the problem is that it's fun to be considered
a horse on F6 is not so easy to find
a completely natural cell, come on
let's see Pay attention to others
parties
Alexandra indirect Zatonskikh Come on
Let's see what Alexandra has prepared
[music]
A
Anna Zatonskikh basically plays Russian
party for a very long time, I think it's the main one
main debut
In her repertoire because even
in the games we played together with
Mountain France vs Team America
quite a long time ago Anya then
used the Russian party and
[music]
very interesting lately
used very often
Russian chess players
[music]
10 minutes
and there you need to constantly do very
exact move so I'm not sure it seems
It seems to me that this option cannot be repeated in
principle
Impossible
maybe some choice
I'm looking at his facial expression
like it's trying to do something
remember that's how I look I think that's it
this facial expression reminds me of
my own thoughts I think not a fact
or I don't remember anything
Yes, I finally succeeded
see accident
[music]
and Koryakina and even himself
Karyakin Karlana is probably the most like this
last batch
where it was played but they just translated it
to another classic position where Seryozha
Karyakin 24 knight C6 played D4 and
Fabiana played D5 is 6 seconds
and so they played such a classic
there is a diagram of C5 elephant
which can also turn out
French change, that is, here too
a matter of taste. So I think, Maybe Anya
thinks about what position she would have
nice to play easier to play she too
plays the French defense yes Again
You see
our participants have this principle
they have enough high level
universal style they play very
many openings they understand a lot
opening schemes And sometimes it seems to be done
two or three walk and you don’t understand at all
than what is a man sitting and thinking about
in fact, maybe he already sees
somewhere on the twentieth position on the move
not from the Russian party, but from the French one
protection Yes, he and she are trying maybe
understand
does she lose pace in any way?
doesn’t lose that is, is it worth going
For example
the natural move in this position was
just a horse for example
she's actually thinking
arrangement of figures Maybe she is still
trying to understand because she is big
Arsenal has a choice
Which position will be unpleasant for her?
What positions can her opponent be in?
your opponent knows worse or maybe
less less ready it seems that too
probably has its meaning but when you
you play against Alexandra Kosteniuk I
I wouldn't waste time
she has questions that seem to me
absolutely not necessary because it's time
thirty is very little I think it’s necessary
solve specific problems and especially in
Russian party, in principle, it seems to me
already
lose so quickly in principle
Completely impossible I usually
you get a slightly worse position even if
you didn't remember the option of course and
then you try to live with her
This is certainly not the most pleasant feeling
for a chess player but sometimes you have to
make a choice
ku
concrete struggle
and White can immediately identify as many as three
elephant D7 what is happening now on
in the party Abdumalik Sebag
Spanish chance, again, he has a lot
good repertoire classical repertoire
Spanish party she
she almost always uses
the second batch turned out to be black
hers is not as simple as a tournament
debut debut in french
and she
showed very well
and a very good understanding of the position that
which makes me happy
classic won't say much
Spanish version
maybe it was a problem with
broadcast
in this position there are several moves I think
blacks have it
Well, Black chose to continue with d6 And
[music]
here actually what plans are possible
classic plan lately
especially at a high level very often
that is, d6 black already wants to just go
horses again and take this elephant and
basically a favorite sequel
lately it's to play a three a three
in fact, Yes, they don’t play anymore No
use such classic plans
believe that, in principle, there is a special advantage
can't stand all these positions anymore
played and known Actually the move
3 leads to such a very interesting fight
than I hope that they interfere with the move of D5
then after 3.003
that is, this is how they interpret it
position in principle and in fact
appear even in my analyzes
very interesting idea to fold 4 very
there are often a lot of elephants here
pool elephant 4 bishop e6 and here
for example on Solnechny 4
the most I think strongly even though this is an E3 elephant
a lot of games were played especially
lately and I want to see
really What's in store
chess players I think that Maria
I prepared three saddles for years because
there are a lot of developments in this version
made by French chess players
also very often used
favorite option and there is such a fashion in
France
as I said, for example, here is a choice
Russian party It is this option in
Lately
observed in Russian parties
chess players means they
analyzed this idea at the meeting
Maybe
this is completely normal and well
French chess players don't often
gets together but they are very very
love chess and have a lot of ideas
sometimes of course they don't survive the test
computer But in reality this is what
I wonder what uh
ideas Well, sometimes they have a lot of ideas
interesting colossal and which is not so
often an idea allows you to develop a whole
debut, that is, maybe that’s enough
only for one party Well, for example in
at the moment that is three
they survived concentrics Yes, and they
analyzed deeply enough if
Maxim Vasiliev actually uses this
at a high level this means that
position
Yes, not only the game provides
many opportunities for creativity
nanocynic for yesterday lost against
Irina is certainly more beautiful today
will try to win back somehow, I think so
will happen
apparently to make it easier for me
comment That is, I don’t even
I remember that she used it in her
practice accepted Queen's Gambit Me too
and there is, well, no, E5 on E4, basically
Five is one of the main and
forced in continuation That's why I
I think I'm not sure Harika
they also used more than four in their
practice because she is very careful
player
I'll see again of course
[music]
she chose the option
a long time ago
According to my data, this position is always
was assessed in favor of whites and quite
stable
White has a fairly stable advantage then
there is anyway if we look at
participating watches turn out just right
spent 10 minutes less time I
I don't think she was very surprised
hariku but maybe still a little Her
succeeded But let me just check for
actually
have you encountered this in the practice of harike?
because that's what I'm most curious about
that I prepared so much
to these two chess players of his Well, just
sports career that I have already studied them
debut And in fact I would really like
curious
look
We'll see
In fact
a huge number of parties, as I understand it
what are they
categories were still played by all these youth
championships
Well, first of all, here’s what the statistics show in
my
database
data date here it is schizophrenic
absolutely a state where I don’t even know
what language do I say yes and in which
Harike party statistics
is that it is accepted queen
met in practice only four times
can you imagine this for a chess player?
level means Nana made a choice in
the benefit of a very rare continuation A
I think that, in principle, Harika is not
will start sleeping Before 4:00 to 54 but very
often there will be knight 3 and with this option
happened in the party only happened
one time she played against pretty
weak chess and
which options I chose
said the word four step he is enough
simple and
[music]
So Nana was unsure
that is, what move will Harika make?
already after eating the horse up to 4 that is She
was based, in my opinion, simply on
last theoretical games
That's all I tried to somehow catch
surprise your rival. It's perfect.
normal tactics that are used in
semeshakhmatists, in principle, seem to
just in case you should always have
one option Even if it represents
carries a certain amount of risk
and this is what it really is
poker tactics can be maybe not
all chess players because sometimes they are very
it is important to play a position that is very
you know well which one
healthy Well, for example, even Magnus to
He loves very much
to such positions that may be
they don't even represent anything special
positionally but they
carry themselves
very playful character where there is a lot
struggle and where sometimes he surprises his
opponents who are not quite ready
Let's say which option do you remember?
you remember the debut from Magnus’s repertoire
I think there's plenty to choose from
even in the latest tournaments If
I was completely amazed when Magnus
played the defense of the Ufa pepper or something
Modern just black
I was so surprised because
which is also not typical of his style but
Magnus He's a player and that's the quality of me
she simply amazes and delights and
I admire it, it seems so
important quality especially for
modern chess player save here
take this certain amount of risk
[applause]
this quality is actually it
amazing few especially here
modern chess at the elite level
is capable of this because everyone is sitting
work, conduct training, know the theory
sometimes up to 30-40 years old, that is, creative
I don’t even know where the component is
starts in some batches therefore
a lot of draws because it's not worth it
forget that chess players work
I don’t know for 7-8 hours minimum money
professional level is very
hard exhausting work and I will tear you apart
I don't even want this to remain
creative component Because when
your standings
you don't want to take that risk then
I want to save the result of playing
to save the result and this
Magnus quality
it makes me very excited as a player
respect admiration basically you know
when he plays blitz on twitch that is mine
favorite option that recently became
he likes to use it very regularly
play the first moves no matter what
make white with black C6 and 6 Queen for
five king to 8 and queen 8 rearranged
cutter with the king And after that he says
now let's play
Because I don't quite follow
modern technologies but I remembered
case from the last World Cup
Rapid where I think Magnus played Well he
chose continuation at e-4.55 tried
put
school
there is something in him he kept from the heart
baby and in fact this is
dandy
queen w5 Of course we called me
the smile position was actually maybe
be configured as if the state itself is already
in principle led to his death, but the idea
how good
Let's see what happened
Yes, we didn’t look, we didn’t get to
parties
C4 C6 D5
Elizabeth wanted to play the Slavic Defense
Well, lately she too
avoids
debut developments Very often I
noticed even in Georgian parties
chess players and we saw yes yesterday in
Nana's party is what she chose is not the best
fundamental continuation
C4
and interpreted it too, maybe not
in the best possible way
here they turned into something yes Elizabeth
switched to Slavic, maybe she is her
I would cook it anyway if it were white
left before 4 and
you're such a bit of a tricky continuation
it leaves White the opportunity if
If it weren't for Elizabeth, she wouldn't have gone into a scheme with
g67 would go to the traditional scheme with
with the bishop on e6 they leave the rush behind
is also an opportunity we have often seen in
games play G4
don't castle leave the king in
center
This is the trick of the scheme
who use but
basically Elizabeth decided
choose a scheme with an elephant on the ground Let's say
can be shown here
Yes here
if you just go to the Miran schemes
What do white people really want?
bishop E2 let's wait until castling Yes
let's say they go very often
horse
c32
and now it's starting
examine and how much it is 5
four more appear Here they are saving
you even have the opportunity to go into a long
castling depends of course on how
put the pieces black sometimes they
They also translate the diagrams they present
want to go again 8 Well then he also wants to
up to 4 It seems to me that then in comparison
with miran white in some positions superfluous
you're as far as I remember, but then again I
I analyzed these positions for a long time
I mainly play you debut and E4 Well
of course when you watch the games that
played at a high level
games in tournaments, that is, of course in
aware of opening ideas but maybe we don't
we know all the subtleties yes again
subtleties of analysis
where exactly
need to play 4
but as an idea it is in the air but
Elizabeth apparently too
I decided to play more closely without all of them
adventures I think I'm thinking again
about which position is easier for her to play?
there is this position of Slavic defense with
elephant
she gives him a very positional position
where again there is a lot of No, you see
white for now
often white people take it too
at 3 because at B2 he is already completely
not suitable, that is, they are trying
improve your figures
I think this leads to a very Calm
fight that's what I think
It seems to me that now the participants
played out the theory and probably thought
on almost all boards
continue to further develop the party and
choose plans That is, the first move is
done
very often this is the time indicator
when is the first time actually
you think about it, he's talking about that, that is
where basically the preparation ends
and where the person the player starts to play Himself
At what point do you start playing?
computer training is very important
important role in modern chess and
sometimes 30 moves are made on the clock
just an hour 30 hour 40
Yana I don’t remember everything, it happens very often
such a party
at 30 moves he already has a slight advantage
and the clock says 40
it is very nice
all the most resistant who do not sleep during this
time
question Elmira Do they often tell you that
you look a lot like the main character
cult Soviet blockbuster Irony
fate or enjoy your bath
Well, I actually talked a lot
about this movie yesterday I love it very much and
but no thanks for the compliment I don’t know
even how to respond to compliments but
you've never been confused
never confused but am I very ready
Badly
actually I don't know I didn't try
no one has poisoned their jellied fish yet
Try it for real
really touches our essence
our childhood
our Faith is good, beautiful in principle
What
What is chess for us?
maybe symbolically
you can draw a parallel
I'll have to learn Polish too
apparently
just like
at all
as if according to the Stanislav method
Stanislavsky will be entering already
in the image of the heroine is also a question, but I sing
actually in this movie
No I may not be that good but very
I love to sing about this when we had
It's already over All the ideas then we'll sing
sooner or later who has what black who
one could sing an ode to women
Shakhmatov
also a question for me from Vladimir Fomin
Nastya Krylovich you count
FIDE correspondent How did you get into yourself
floyz was invited to this tournament
invited
everything is absolutely true actually I am
Just like Elmira, I really love women’s
chess women's tournaments And I'm very happy
because this is finally happening
wonderful super tournament we held
huge number of hours watching
video broadcast of the cup tournament
Simfeld and finally we are here
Women's super tournament is taking place
We are incredibly happy and thank you very much
of course for the invitation from
organizers of this competition Well
invited invited not worth it I think
devalue professional qualities
Anastasia in short as a journalist for me
I think she's still beautiful
journalist and
it helps me not to do simple work and
complements me and feel the guitars to her
hand over to the last one
the day when we will perform Russian
romances Yes, for us and for me in this
actually helped here in my opinion
even said at one point that he was
concentration of women in this building
probably never happened, that is, with us
woman commentators women players and
It's wonderful it really is
So nice that maybe he even
feel a little uncomfortable because
what threatens him
I was also staggered, actually
satin satin can also stretch
for those who don’t know we are hosting
English is coming at the same time as us
broadcast literally into the next room and
Jennifer shahada morris went
official team american
commentators who work here already I
I think about 10 years
and they are very popular insanely popular
and I think they made a lot of contributions
to them in American chess to come
in American chess I am simply priceless
I think of course it was done on
American modes
very emotional emotional I think
we do this I think in the Russian way
with my emotions I think it's time
bring a Cheburashka I think for the next one
tour
It's okay to say yes to childhood
and one more question Last from the chat and
then we’ll return to Elmira’s games again
there were no thoughts of returning to my native land
Moldovan Federation and share your
knowledge and experience with Moldovan
chess players and generally contribute
to popularize chess in the country
in fact I come back very often
I am grateful that I grew up in this country and in
principle and under the Soviet Union in
Moldova was such
may be
and a student of the Soviet chess school and
Moldovan chess school and chess
seubacha
Communication with me also gave me a lot
leading Moldovan chess players And I
very often quite recently I was in
I don’t know where I played as a child
x number of tournaments
and usually when you return already
adult place
which are so
played an important role in your life it seems
everything seems so small because
when as a child it all seems and
great and grandiose actually not
here is the Moldavian chess club
very beautiful and when in it
come back too
you realize how much with architectural
from the building's point of view it is graceful
and there are very beautiful chess tables and I
I often meet chess players, sometimes I give
sessions, that is, Well, unfortunately, Still,
I have two children
I don't get out very often
they like to play a tournament for example
return to Chisinau every summer
if I manage to get out and
accompany them I do it with joy
not lost, but the desire to play your
home country
again, how would I play for the Moldovan
team for a very long time and when I accepted
choice to play for the French national team
it's not just a personal choice it seems
me too and adult choices I still
became an adult and all the years
the rulings were such my personality I
already spent in France and for
it seemed to me at that time
logical enough for me to imagine
French national team
and I don't
it's so easy to be satisfied, that is, to accept
this choice is not so not so easy and
[music]
change it, unfortunately it doesn’t work for me either
easy I don't even think it makes sense
that doesn't even make sense It seems to me that
a person must be very
consistent in his choice and
in my actions I for example
I even thought about the rules
that exist on the given day of the feed
about treason simply national
separation I don’t even know National
Federation It seems to me that maybe
It’s worth limiting this possibility to uh
two times a sports career, that is
It’s still a very choice for an athlete
important it is conscious must be conscious
and in principle it seems to me that even here
the rules that were written and which
caused the athlete to move to different
They remind me a little of the federations
as if
we are not talking about commercial contracts here
not first of all This is not Indian This is not the NHL This
not football, that is, we are still talking about
athletes who represent the country
and present it to me with pride
It seems like there are life situations where
Just you're living
married You moved and again this choice
he is very consciously connected more with
change in life situation than with
some kind of commercial event
there is, it seems to me that it would be worth it
think about it and really be
maybe change this rule Well at least
give it more like that
noble look That is, it’s still for me
seems very important so how would I
I don't even think about it
it was hard enough to do already
first time this choice and I basically
I'm proud of what I represent now
the French national team for a very long time and I
played a lot of Olympics for the national team
Moldavi Gina and on the first board and
I remember this with trepidation, I am my
when I really wanted to play 13
games in every Olympics And now I
I think when is the day off
Well, yes, I also played on the first board
then all the time and this was not the case
the person who could replace you
it's just really quite like
I had more energy than desire and motivation
here's the last one played the last one
Olympics in Batumi after a long time
break
I realized how difficult it is for me
managed to play out only in the second
half the tournament and even by some miracle
The French team got 94 places I
I'm not entirely sure we deserved it
But
these tournaments are very grueling and even
as an indicator that Russian
the team was left without medals and says
there was a lot of the latter where as
once Alexandra Costume played with Jamie
John I'm just bleeding
when I remember Yes, this party and
it's easy to even imagine
all the emotions you go through
chess player for a sense of responsibility I
I don't know, it's terrible, you're just terrible
pressure and you're already reproaching yourself so much
of course, for any move, and I even
I can't imagine
this feeling of guilt Yes that carries on
yourself an athlete in any sport well
when the team just loses medals and I
I hope that in the future, even soon
there will be a team championship world championship
that is
about it
forget
our tournament then she played Zatonsky
for a long time for Ukraine and in the same way
after moving to and living here for some time
time has changed the Federation Yes and it is possible
again remember Alexandra’s costume
who probably lives in three countries
in fact, that is, she is also in Russia
America and France Maybe you
you're worth more, even Elvira might be theirs
There are even more of these countries in Switzerland. I even
Don't know
She's such a cosmopolitan person
she still remains
she is still a representative
after all, Russia plays on the first board
in recent years for collecting and she has
proudly represents her country
very bright brightly expressed again uh
sense of responsibility she every
team tournament plays simply with this
dedication which Well, sometimes you don't
you will see it on the entire national team
is she is a true leader
team she is a very sensitive person she
she's just an incredible role model
is a true fighter simply
I mean, I don't know. In the literal sense of it.
words as magma is said is
a true Viking player all the time
fights for
as if for raising the bar, that is
it constantly takes on new heights
so amazing
when a person wins for the fourth time
The world championship is certainly not that easy anymore
find motivation and literally through
wins tournaments for a couple of weeks
proves that I think that the strongest
the world is still and what
he has
still left
somewhere strength to play chess
analyze all the time I see her
constantly stream and actively participate
commentator
it just says a lot of love to
chess and about sincerely about sincerely
I still love this game
seek the idea of ​​getting from it
pleasure
And
desire to win desire desire
win yes
actually at some point
I even asked her a question from Pobeda, as it were
you still get one like this
emotional pleasure
despite the fact that the defeat is complete
destructive effect on the psyche
chess player and
the answer actually didn't come to her that way
just because especially on this
level chess player he takes Victory
very calm because for granted
it goes without saying, of course, because he
sets up he basically considers himself
obliged to win he fights for victory
in every tournament in every game
Unfortunately, defeat for me personally
it was always such a little death
because some part of you is always
remains on the board if you lose
always trying to analyze
reasons for the defeat what went wrong
what mistakes were made and they
very very painful unfortunately these
wounds don't heal easily
In fact
those games that you will lose if you
at least you really analyze them
trying not to repeat the mistakes that
you did it, I think it’s also important
quality for any chess player who
even just learning to play chess
always analyze your games as
lost so won every time
getting better and better of course We
we learn mainly from lost games
this is basically the most important thing
source
[laughter]
Well, basically I know Alexandra. For example, I
I can even share such a secret
information that she even records her
blitz games analyzed by him
she has a phenomenal memory
she has been accustomed to this since childhood, that is,
she has absolute discipline and she
truly an incredible professional
business before we go to pause
let's take a quick look please
all parties that
actually Pay attention to Valentina
Cousin never made a move And from that
moment after you see she really
maybe again it can’t
decide on a plan That is, she thinks
I played her 6 But which one should I choose?
scheme with an elephant for life wait for now
whites will go E5 or take it before eating
and go to the circuit with E5 but this is not
reminds me of yesterday's game exactly the same
somewhere around the tenth move even before
10 years old she's exactly the same I'm thinking
for quite a long time again what do I need
it seems like it's not for her at all
it may be typical for her
I also analyzed my games
analyzed how she spends
time in debut Should she be maybe a
sometimes
deeper
think at some moments, that is, well
as if, again, in chess jargon
slap
I know what the second one is
the coach gave instructions as a child. Just
sit holding hands no sit on hands
these are actually very valuable
valuable advice that I sometimes give to my
for children yes Just sit down and think and
think Yes, don't spank in this case
Half an hour is probably still a little bit
Yesterday we were just with Mikhail too much
Khodorkovsky discussed this here Captain
the women's team always gave advice and
reminded me of him almost before
each than please don't think more
10 minutes above him the move resembled a girl
you understand as a practical point
Well, yes, this advice is basically
not bad but it seems to me that
sometimes it’s very important. Exactly in some
moments to stop
and think if this is exactly the position
the position for her represents some kind of
complexity of interpretation I don’t know what it’s for
getting ready I'm not entirely sure that Irina
played with the transit beginning again
their debut practice
after all, we are talking about the strongest
chess players of the world I think that Valya
Now she's thinking about something other than her own
next move she's thinking I'm thinking about
interpretation of the whole blizzard, that is, I
I think I'll have time
enough but she should be maybe
understand now
It's important to have a plan especially in a snowstorm.
Spire How to place the pieces correctly and
even in the color stage I think she will be
it's easier to play
here, for example, I understand her very well
next batch
went to 4 black
In fact
Wait, I have to understand now
French change
they're moving, I want to understand
very strange position That is
creative I think maybe
Alexandra was even interested in this position
ready because I have to make a move after all
The Lion King 1 Well actually not at all
human Yes it turns out black
have already made two moves with the bishop, so he
there is a seed then four words came
May be
there's actually something about it now
threatens But on the other hand you understand
such positions
Black's pieces are very valuable
clumsy you know after all
In principle, the horse on E4 is not entirely stable
at the same time, in the Russian party very often
play D5 C6 supports either like 55
and now there’s an elephant. Go to this place. Go to B4
maybe like the Lion King one move
completely normal
then it seems to me that this is homemade
preparation is already on both sides because
basically look at
interpretation of the Black opening
4 king F1 and back
They are them again
deprived White of castling and again and
improved positions actually
actually very good He gave a step on
B4 The Lion King he went back found
castling That is, I’m interested now
in fact, how will the whites be
how to play without castling?
walk horse 3
I would spontaneously make a move consi 3
Don't know
That's what she thought, she remembered this
option maybe you can imagine yes in
in principle, in principle, remember this
I don't know if you haven't looked at this before
I can't imagine the party at all
We'll talk about this more after our
break
How
is actually a theoretical position and
here sometimes white people take advantage of you
go H3 and these are very often translated
positions
she is considered a little better than whites because
that with as many as three elephant H5 how would he behave
feels very uncomfortable and you can even
at some point
and then I don’t know how to play this position
translation konyash 2 F4 understand
very, very uncomfortable, the opposition is not
I like it, not the most pleasant
further Let's go Let's go Let's see
Maria is thinking about her move Kharko
zagnidze you and I stopped that
the moment when Yes she went 3 that is she
carried out the plan with B4 actually This is it
typical plan that is currently being carried out
hare no horse B3 Just her
moves the knight Yes to a very good square
and at the same time that blacks always threaten
you tilt your horse to such positions
4 and
3 is very, very good At the same time She
allows you to later remove the horse
with D2, that is, let’s even say
such typical qualities of victims here
Now if they are buried at 3
Well, at least do it
4 or
some code there is completely careless
the idea appears to be simply purely victims
quality let's say sum two bishop D2 let's say
so to save Yes in such positions
very often you can just donate
ideas then 200 each Another rook like this
queen that I understand what really
white simple as if I’m just showing
that such an idea is absolutely
Elementary and plan sconey one D3
firstly, it restricts blacks in general
basically in all possibilities
attackers and
D3 she's very like that
natural cell is good
and the last party that we didn't
returned this party Although found or
Pets
nothing much happened
again a standard plan for what
some position
white has such a tempting E5 cell
here is the horse on it
it really depends again
In fact, it’s also not such a simple position
because at some point the Blacks
the moves will also run out
white a little more space and for me
it seems that black is needed in this position
show some creativity
what can be done here
offer
where is the elephant in these positions?
they bring out a black elephant I don’t want to
put it on the pool just to
understand about the bad elephant Yes if it is black
Lana will put on the topic we often talk about
this is in the French broadcast but I
I guess, that
everyone knows each other here
no I think it’s purely so clear
there's an elephant in the pool, he's such a bad elephant
he is limited practically by his pawns
turns into a pawn
I don’t want to put it on E6 like that
But then I don’t quite understand why I was there
move made Rook 8
that is, a little
doesn't match you get lost Sometimes you
you seem to be making a natural move, but
really Then why is it needed?
Laden and 8 I think this was it
definite loss of pace
Is it possible to code horse F10
So what about the elephant?
it turned out to be checkers
it's such a pity it's a pity I just have to put it
but I can not
actually I think we should go on
break and after it we will again
Let's look carefully at the positions and
stay with us
[music]
I even imagined this position
I still think what position she goes
in what position will there be a chance to confuse your
opponent and this position turned out to be
board, I thought it was time for me to make a video
dance around the fire, that is, and
call on a higher power because I'm already
greek gods this time greek gods
were kind to us and but I know that
this is a very easy share, the captain's share and
really Yes Sometimes you wonder
how to place the players because more than once
they came to you with these questions
why am I playing for the third time with black or
second time with black And I want to play
white and so on That is, accept
decision must be taken responsibility
still has to be the captain Yes, of course
I'm very happy in principle that in my
the team is very
very good team spirit
noble all the girls are very
they seem to be sensitive to my
decisions are always prepared and I think
the result is absolutely amazing
that there are no participants in this tournament
I don't think there is a single team member
there is I see that a member of the club team Well
which I played in the last round
of course in fact In principle it is
[music]
represents the national team because
for the team but she plays nanoja gnidze
white this is not news on the channel saishvili
And
Lilia Khishvili and with spare salomel To
there is a very strong team that
won the European Cup several times
two representatives from this team
play in this tournament
I think we were invited to this
the little sister's tournament was just there
question from our TV viewers about
Why don't Muzychuk's sisters play? Why
the world champion is not playing
I don't quite know the reasons, I think
that maybe there is a tournament in principle
organized at the last moment
everyone managed to change their plans of course
same sister-Muzinchuk is just one
of the leading leading chess players in the world and
it would be interesting to see
how would they play in this tournament I
I think next year basically
this will be an opportunity Yes, the chess player in
In principle, a schedule has been drawn up in advance
tournaments they Maybe they all played by the way
Gibraltar literally a week before the start
of this tournament We all know what
the chess player had difficulty obtaining
visas
sometimes planned preparation fees
chess players have fundamentally changed
professional schedule because
international chess federation
announced the Candidates Tournament
Yes, and it’s for you in the Grand Prix cycle to these
tournaments need to prepare And sometimes
for months maybe this is basically
is the main reason why
that the tongue sisters didn’t come to play
this tournament I understand very well if
goal to win the Candidates Tournament in
In principle, it seems to me that it is necessary to
there are two or three months I’m starting already
until the New Year New Year Come on
let's see but in fact the question was about
even if there are Ukrainian chess players here
that is, in fact, no, but in fact
we know that she is Zatotskikh and Irina
Krashena were actually born in Ukraine
and she also played for Zatonsky for many years
Ukrainian national team Ukraine may be
this will at least console me somehow
fans fans Well look at everything
Anya thinks Bye Let's see she
chooses she wants yes Also understand well
here's Anya of course
[music]
which, in principle, is very inherent in her
parts is the color of the note, that is, for it
this is the situation
completely ordinary, that is, she is completely
can leave it for the last 20 moves
five minutes to myself I think this is all
characteristic of Ukrainian chess players if
remember Yes, who play for a very long time
for the Ukrainian team which I think
their colleagues
also gave me a heart attack, but at the same time
plays
note stage just encore
Look, Tanya went as if at five o'clock
yes, it seems to me that this is
the strongest leaves in this position and is very
I would like to understand basically what happened
prepared by Alexander Well, let's go to
We’ll come back to this again Yes, let’s move on now
again This is the main strategic
the idea in this position suggested this move
instantly Yes, like a real Frenchman
I'm not a real process like
children's chess school products
change
such positions Let's see yeah What
happened But you see, in principle, if
they look played A3 female
moved to
option to fold 4 which was offered
me 3 is the strongest sequel
knight D4 this is all a theoretical position
bishop up to 4 food knight D5 C5 and H3 Marie
took a photo You see I'm just about
he said yes, if white would take ph3
on
for black ones they would take it to F3 I think that
Maria in between would have taken to E7
Then I'd take a look
Yes
and would probably move to this position
Of course she could also go to
multi-colored Well, it seems to me that
knight D7 normal plays firji three and
still better I think but
in these positions. Therefore, in principle
our 3 is considered the strongest continuation
elephant E6 this is very important and an alternative
H3 It seems to me that she was still in this position
It seems to me that A4 is used very often
at a high level Yes, and here, in my opinion, I
it seems black is still walking elephant E6
That is, if black doesn't matter
I have prepared six, like three
It helps them. Let's see what
did Maria she went horse at 4
Well, there's an elephant B3
No, well, basically it’s perfect
natural course That is, you want to
me at four Well, it’s already necessary here
beat
and already play this position
I'm not sure what I was looking through
the games in this version are for white
they kept exactly two horses for themselves.
I guess I'm not quite the same
I'm getting my bearings Okay, let's see
end 4
And
I think blacks need to decide somehow
question with this dark-squared bishop for now
When in principle it is
characteristic that is
such a bad piece in this position here
I beat Zhans just in the B3 CB position
[music]
What can I go again A4 And what should I
like it 5 maybe white themselves
maybe A4 you know
let's go again and here's a typical technique
A4 And you decide in principle
the knight will go to 24 despite this
the visible weakness of these pawns can be Rook
would be eight but in principle 24 such fields Then
I don't like it if there was a B4
then imagine what it is
4 such a typical technique I think that
on the other hand, if you don’t go to the
White often plays in such positions
B4 is also a typical technique, maybe
be one by four or through D2 B4
Despite the fact that it seems
gives White the opportunity to immediately jump to
D5
maybe she wants to exchange him through
just knight B6
yet again
do I want to play this position with a knight
against the bishop
maybe it's not so scary after all
[music]
It seems to me that yes blacks should
can be carried out up to 5
again, I have some kind of static
it's time that it's like this
the ratio of the figure saw the party
Maxima vs.
I don’t quite remember Lvon Ronyan Yes
how it turned out and the lemon spent D5
Maxim somehow successfully maneuvered and he
played Exactly against this bishop
I know maybe it’s not worth exchanging
straightaway
I don’t want to leave the elephant F6
force
maybe White can play easier here
actually
they can put the knight on D5 and move
yours here B4 Well, a little easier this way
they are the most Well, it’s like a pleasant position
constantly have to think about
equation
Let's see what's happening
Yes, when the white horses went alone they began
barely translate
again, along the way, he doesn’t give care to the horses five
Same
four eight
5 it seems Rook B6 was such a loss
Tempo horse 4 jumped Yes on the other
sides
on the other hand, in principle, with Ferdina
e6 That is, you are no longer given
reorganize and place the knight on D3
I still have to make one
basically
a move that is completely natural is the bishop
5 had to be withdrawn and Harika now
thinks no, it seems to me that the water is [ __ ] 7
Quite naturally no, that is
breed one with the idea of ​​knight D3 and be
maybe then even translate bishop H4 bishop
G3 and grab onto the E5 pawn
It seems to me that at first maybe
three and
it is always possible to defend the pawn
E4 with F3
It seems to me that there are already a lot of white people here
big advantage
I don't quite see
what are blacks planning?
I still can't understand
[music]
I just think if the possibility of cunnilingus 4
Well that is the first
the exercise must first be taken Take m
one move was actually some kind
like this
C3 yes that is he gives me seven rings 3 weight 1
it probably won't go away anymore
wait, let's count
Yes no, dress up alone uh quite
it is possible that the idea always excludes something in
in principle no in principle how to be
maybe she planned cunnilingus A4 because
What
the knight hangs on C4 But even if the knight hangs
on C4 there is attached one will hang
Mounted on C6 But on the other hand on horseback
four queens 4 if the move is the 5th
simple and
Well, let's see if we
Let's make some income that allows
us ideas
[music]
carried out I don’t know Which
[laughter]
king H1 because then already
I need something at least useful
I don't see anything more useful yet
the owner's move alone then what's the matter
very difficult Yes, it’s not that simple
actually make a mistake and
that is, after the elephant 5 at least reproduce
one so natural can
actually it came to us with the idea
firstly, I don’t want to give away the elephant and
carry a little trap Maybe she
wants to change it by going where the family
at the same time protect the E5 pawn
wait, what about an elephant?
still some appear here again
check on 24
that he was, in principle, defending another pawn, I didn’t
I know white people in principle
they would threaten to take
CD but I don't quite understand it
let's see the latest batch
list let's go break
come on what happened yes see elizabeth
she
played
in D7 then I talked about this idea very much
Black often plays knights in D7 to
exchange this knight for E5
knight bd7 is actually impossible
that is, the pawn hangs on C6 and the end of D7
is such a strategic idea
then the blacks still want it again
to be carried out at some point
it felt like 3
in principle, whatever the whites want here, they will
forced to probably beat 5 in
at some point determine the structure
most likely that is a CD
blacks will take it so as not to stay
with weakness C6 and will play like this
calm position
basically
limits black opportunities
carrying out
something you can’t protect Just right away
more or less I don’t know where to higher what
here blacks have to switch
actually for other ideas
and again, you don’t need to solve this one
bishop problem like how to bishop F3 Rook
would 8 why couldn't even everyone can
be or wants to go again the elephant on 6
carry out such an idea Yes, everything is quite possible
maybe that's why there were at least 8 I think
with which one Well yes, I'm trying to understand which one
the idea was played by Diablo Come on
Let's see what if CD CD is basically like
it would be perfect
there were standard ones
just defended myself against the idea of ​​BC
along the way, she was proud to take whether it threatened
take on C4 not entirely sure Yes weaken
so
and therefore
not only elephant 6 again
I don't know again
everyone else after our short
break stay with us please
Don't leave, don't fall asleep, the most important thing is
[music]
and many more
We're back at the studio, sorry about that
minor technical difficulties But really
in fact they say that we had no sound
for a while and but I know that ours
the audience even tried to read lips
what I said I hope you succeeded though
would like to see those analyzes and the moves that we
showed on the diagram And thank you for that
that you stay with us I think that these
all problems will be solved today and more of them
will not get information
During this time we have several questions and
one of the questions seems to me very
logical why Valentina Kunina
only 17 minutes left after literally
14 moves Let's see
It seems to me that most likely Valentina
plays this pattern for the first time first
very logical explanation she is wrong
easy to interpret because
you see she translated it
Indian beginnings What did I talk about where
blacks moved
the whole fight on the queen's flank plan
there is something completely standard
is completely standard
strategic idea while
usually the bishop stands on B7 What gives
white
opportunity to attack the black king
basically you see Irina did everything
the planned moves I talked about
started
one
She had to go again already 4 that is
four put the bishop on F4 not quite
I'm sure Irina too
threatened what then in principle
this is a standard idea
basically if you want to go see her 3
at some point you can go to 6g5 Yes and
be left without a figure
and then no, even if as many as 4 have not been played
Yes, for example, if you have planned to leave
horse 3 then after G5 You'll just be left without
the figure is exactly the same, that is, in principle, like me
I'm not entirely sure even in such positions
sometimes you can donate it and even
trying and completely reckless
checkmate sacrifice a couple of pieces but
I think Irina may have prepared
you understand all these moves completely
obvious standard You're just losing
Black also lost tempo on them, but
Valentina I think I got it very much
advantageous version of this opening now
faces an arena question
quite typically strategic
the technique in this position is move 3
because blacks want to weaken
queenside move
A3
get the cells Yes, I would play with white I
often played this position is a three
some kind of standard Well, it seems to me that
scientists are completely fine with this position
Valentina is probably just playing her
for the first time and
it's hard for her and she wastes so much time
First of all, I'm wasting so much time
I don’t know at all, that is, how well
Valentina is struggling and waiting with lag, she said
that in principle he sleeps well Yesterday
interview here nearby Maybe today
she woke up at 5 am failed
fall asleep Yes, it’s quite possible and that’s it
very often slows down the thinking
sometimes in such a situation consciousness is a little
blurred Yes she also said remember
that yesterday I didn’t even understand how 5 passed
minutes at one moment colored That is,
I was 6 minutes more time A in
at some point it became as much as
and the rival had although they found her too
couldn’t explain where to go somewhere
time has run away, that is, it’s in these
moments with open eyes
the fact that the body may not be
copes well with the time difference
because sometimes you see what two are
I did it completely again
standard move in this position She
decided not to go from 3 threatened with 4 H5 on
actually it seems to me after this move
created such a threat to choose a figure
after the elephant is 6 yes but then it appears
such an opportunity C4 even got me
I like this move you understand everything the bishop is on
G6 Valya walks automatically, that is
you see now you have to accept
the decision is purely intuitive, she should
I had to plan them but I liked it
No I'm not C4 white Yes I mean that
on a horse as many as two I think it’s like that too
a typical reaction for blacks could do everything
four which is D4 and then just and B4
you know, or even from either four numbers
he's already six already
in fact, this is also indirect
protection from the people I said
really like
how it went now we'll see
for now it turns out
and in principle Irina is the only one
participant who plays in this tournament
without on the website Well, as if on my own
territory but without any visible jetlag
It seems to me that by the way I remember
the story of when Onishgiri played with Boris
Gelfan in China and wasn’t very good either
great color of notes and Boris needed
make the fortieth move and he has left
3 or 4 minutes and he literally
fell asleep with his eyes open, that is, he
sat thinking about the move Anastasia Sorokina
deputy chief arbiter here she is
it’s just strange from this party
I was waiting for the move there was no addition But this
was the last move before control and he
he was just sitting there and his time was up
position was equal nothing was nothing
it wasn't scary, it wasn't hard to make a move
and thus lost the game and
completely insane actually
still a heavy load on the body
unfortunately it seems like it’s long
flight
[music]
has a big impact on the body and sometimes
sometimes in feminine
much stronger and
[music]
It's not that easy to deal with, of course.
but I understand, yes, sometimes it just goes
you can't do that kind of braking at all
to cope with this you sit and think God
so what am I spending my time on?
logically even explain rationally
It's impossible for yourself too
it seems like mirages in some positions
usually you play with your hand and then you start
calculate literally every move Come on
let's see
little by little
that’s how it happened, that is, absolutely
ecological continuation of the sun 45
naturally she didn’t four me
also change Cannot mean elephant E3
I like this move
castling Well, it seems like a move
natural Yes, was it possible?
here is the opportunity to go here Conte 6 that
the move we planned to make
up to this place of castling yes instead
castling Well, long castling of course
This is probably getting pretty daring
maybe sometimes it reminds me too
some positions of the Scandinavian party
where the Queen constantly walks around the board
there's only one cell for him, well somehow he doesn't
comes across and they use it very often
this ring technique is 6 long
castling I don’t know. In principle it’s possible.
is it in this position 6 to 5
[music]
I don't even know
beat on E5 And then it turns out
option that counts together now
Maybe
knight C6 and immediately falls under Well
once again Sasha's horse
we'll come back again Yes, just straight away
specifically Yes
[music]
I don’t want a horse again either
Although how
would be 56 again very
not so clear
I just want to go here if the elephant is coming
go anyway
the situation has already improved when we are now
gradually
let's create a cooperative option yes
maybe castling then Well, if the knight
for six leads something like this
strange complications here castling already
probably always a little scary
No, I mean castling in principle
instead of
6 it’s still scary to walk in this position
if you haven't calculated it at home with
computer
Yes, what are the consequences after d5? So
castling is probably castling a horse
I like E5 too
what other options does white have?
basically
need to determine the position too
own king
maybe horses contributes to the idea in 3
smoke can't sit
[music]
And what to do with black
horse not 5 I want She herself Wait
Yes, you need to think about it like What am I talking about?
I told the Scandinavian woman there was only one left
cell H4 is actually still on C2 but I
I thought that they were still breeding one turn on
and then we're at 3 Well actually even
there are still four, well look how many
the rate will then be lost already at
news two suns two well done one well
let's say the elephant went to F5 maybe uh
it will even be possible to beat on f7
donate something Well done
look how many ideas arise immediately
a position that was completely simple
maybe it could be like
six as if to demonstrate something
Well, maybe it's not entirely good
editorial office
[music]
The rook will quickly connect the black king
gone how come Well maybe Okay tell us
have to 6 walk just that's of course
just demonstrate that in principle
How can we fend off threats?
F3 is basically just the Queen in reality
in fact, again, I feel very uncomfortable
Maybe again how can we exchange
I don't even know to actually be black
maybe 40
advice
how to protect yourself from F3
I don’t know, maybe I should try somehow
bring out the horse
somehow specifically count the options here
really permissible Just if you take
Unfortunately
available
actually black
[music]
Yes, I put the only one
opportunity and here it’s all for me somehow
I don't really like it but for now
I don’t see specifically. What if
it's completely primitive to go
I thought it was even 4
I start
most likely yes E5 will probably go where
here the elephant is not 6 then the elephant is not 6 and
oils actually show what if
black immediately left to eat then take this
and sometimes take seven
but he sent it there
good decision but I want to punish
I need to think about the law right away
[music]
I thought in this elephant 6 again I'm everything
I want to exchange
I'm not quite sure how
Is this a good editorial?
after all, white can still go
maybe A go back with London 3 in this and
problem after F3 Maybe it will happen again
interesting game Elephant will chase
Maybe you see, after all, we didn’t go 4G
Here the elephant is already e6 Fe, as it were
creates certain difficulties in the position
blacks, that is, in general
even if you just go 34 attack everything
straightaway
and what about White’s position there is not much
weaknesses and the king in F1 is not worth it
Just
it's not that easy to get to, it's worth it
Fine
[music]
Let's try
In fact
Yes, you see it seems
somehow strange too, yes they put white ones
your figure is really everything
Everything interacts securely, which is very
is important and with every move Alexandra creates
actually a new threat so they
I did it, I want to see what it's like
the move was made
[music]
This is probably the only move
this feeling most likely yes Well, you see
I'm still such an obsession Yes they are
also wants to change this bishop and you see
seems to be the size of this elephant
In principle, it’s as if it’s going to be black to breathe
easier Despite the fact that as they would
ready to create weakness for yourself on E6 Well
this weakness is compensated for in exchange
bishops are already a weakness on D4, that is, that’s all
not so scary anymore
opens
What happens if White goes here?
ru I don’t really want to, well then just
back
Well, as Alexandra even told us in
interview yesterday That is, she sometimes even
anticipates where the opponent might be
ready to repeat moves for example game
with elizabeth she went king seven exactly
with that idea to avoid repetition
codes
which the rival foresaw and would be
maybe she was already psychologically ready for
this repetition of moves but she did
such an insidious move by the king Ugu and Sasha in
this moment was no longer ready for anyone
That is, she wanted no. It’s the other way around.
in principle, Sasha is ready to fight in any
I have never seen such a position before
Where she would be ready to agree but
Nothing
in this position Let's see others
there must be some kind of cell
saved
[music]
interesting here it wasn't worse 6 I'm here
I really think if it's like
six why but maybe push to
exchange I wonder if these remain
two horses again it seems that
you understand with 6 knight at 6 queen at 6
If
White will carry out this many plan. Well
I would like an idea with B4 to weaken the pawn on D4
immediately 24 Here after 6 or something
I want to think about whether it’s worth giving away the cage
preference four maybe even
knight 4 because again B3 will not climb
I know
Maybe she didn't want to weaken
[music]
the fact that there is already an idea in 5 is exactly like
would not be consistent for the black position
and black
you know, in principle, white keeps for
there are a lot of possibilities, but for
Black people are completely unclear to me. What is he?
here to do what plan to carry out
free yourself from the weakness of D5 then pawn
on C5 the bishop seems to be weakened; it is no longer
protects and has grown into all the perch at once
will jump to E4, that is, the pawn is faster
the total will collapse, that is, to 5
not so easy just food let's say knight d54
[music]
maybe the horse is burning
apparently apparently it seems that you
get rid of weakness d-6 actually
in fact you are creating another weakness for yourself
C5 that is, it is not so easy to bring D5 into
this position at 5 most likely yes to the knight
H5 G6 probably White wouldn’t take it on
F6 here is the bishop E5 Yes the knight again then
this is a completely different edition
look at the actual scenario
our viewers draw for us
[music]
Jansaya writes for 2 days, probably for sure
will put pressure on the opponent's time
colored white will twist relatively
equal position and the fight is probably like this
was in yesterday's desk When Anna was in
crumbled at the end
I agree that she is Zhenya
has this incredible
the ability to really twist
position in the color note it even to me
the solution is completely unclear
take
de
I don’t know, maybe it’s justified
flash meeting Fridgie 4 don't want to checkmate
attack but I don’t know what it seems to me
I just simplified the task first of all
Black is now completely easy to play
this position she wears is not quite the same
character like
well, that is, like the jeans party yesterday
he had two elephants so torn
position where I constantly had to
fight for diagonals to open lines
and femininity coped with it for me
it seems just brilliant right there the position
but absolutely yes positional character
actually play now after the move
perches again it seems to me like her
much easier I don't quite understand
White's decision to take on E5
and go
just double down the line and be stupid
attack the pawn
Well, an idea with a code appears
definitely how to decide I think
actually there is a little less left
time This is a known desire in general
change your figure as much as possible
forgive somewhere the position is literally F3 in
in principle he stood very well for me
it seems that it doesn’t really interfere with us
interfered, you could go to Face D2 Well
like And it seems to me that Queen T2 and
I don’t know how this move would interfere with G6
Well, there’s even a round for six like that
arose at the next 5 let's see also
six queen neck Well just really
while the same six may not be the same
threat and
Mounted F3 is still very strong in principle
I don't know the figure
You just can’t wait with this decision
determine position
still 11 minutes what is the move now
Twentieth move left 20 dollars
It seems to me that I played a role in
making a decision in this position
hariki with us let us remind you that the position
it worked out
theoretical version of the accepted ferzing
gambit
that you guessed it all was the owner's move
one by five I continue
[laughter]
because the move is actually completely
simple, I can’t think of anything else
I can do it there again too
natural course what actually happens
it seemed to me that Harika used this
this one is not quite
an unusual idea A 3 B4 which is often very
white
play right away
four and leaves as if not used
again
[music]
What's happening on the board She decided
just activate
Because when in fact exactly in
this position we thought about what
what will be Black's next move?
actually it doesn't seem like much to me
she has now created some kind of threat maybe
be even D3 to 4 Well, that is, he wants
somehow activate it can still ride
6 this is what comes to mind first
and uncertainty works
How many pawns are there already on E5? Will there be a rush?
hang therefore white accordingly
[music]
there
Maybe just
I don’t even know, maybe it’s an elephant
he'll just give knight 3 Rook 3 and just
protect pawn on tactical no Yes
no action Not 5 But this
not enough Yes it doesn't work
Well done 3 is actually move C
from a practical point of view again very
interesting because it's like a lock
In fact
I don’t know if, in principle, at least three get along
pass then then 3 kunds maybe not
quite an accurate move Well, apparently D3 was threatening
somehow
3 years
hanging Well yeah Well okay I came then
All these ideas don’t go away yet. Well, okay
let's say yes Well, here I'm not very good anymore
I like it when someone is already a threat
appear of course yes I understand that
maybe it’s not really that specific either
in fact and well yes it passes
position to imprison oneself very much
actually
interesting ideas, that is, the owners 3
Nice words
What to do
elections
[music]
What to do
and the pawn is again not so easy on
actually decide Yes, interesting
but the position that has arisen, which is now
board, that is, it is also necessary while he thinks But
actually probably
Let's see, maybe even until 4
the one who
I think it's better to hold off on this
move because actually no
there cunnilingus 4 after 4 if 3 4 I don’t know
[music]
exchanged it after all
must be saved Is it possible the sun 5 on
actually finally put it
[music]
I don't like him that much, that's how I see it
then we'll drink four kondili
probably a pawn
you see how it’s already the end of one too
yet again
interesting no here's the sun 5 at least for me
like it completely natural
put it diagonally
what to do it seems the sun is coming in again
good
protect that is, you are no longer alone from
have an easy life and make moves like this
now on the other side
I think it will be easy later
any of them
brand 4 worse attack Yes of course
I don’t know, maybe about three
knight until move 4 is good in principle but again
we'll block you won't block us
now I really like this move
in fact
shot at the game and maybe he’s thinking
right now it seems
maybe she is still thinking about the move Rook B8
I don't know you know activate too
rook bring one more piece instead of 5
let's say I don't know what
to do on D3, in principle, White has this
a small threat still remains for them
need to eat this pawn
such a nail in White’s position after all
walking on glass she is very dangerous Well you
probably now you don’t threaten anyway
beat her because the knight is not four
Yes, of course, on occasion
case, yes, and protect the cell alone, that is
the other side may have eight queens
D3 then get along well I don’t know how to play
very cunning to somehow win like that Well yes
I don’t know, it’s possible at all Well, the sun is again
I still like it somehow
position let's see what it is
one of the most interesting games today
what let's see what's going on
in general in the party uh Although they found it to sing
Wait where did it go
this idea that I said like six
again
eight
basically she solved the problem of bad
the elephant who spoke And in principle
to me
quite interesting She solved this
task
or C5
or CD, that is, I’m not coming here
I completely understand, maybe it was after all
better
how not to define the structure as it were
she's a bit of a bishop for one instead of C5
go CD let's say here yes Well I know
C5 is still like that for me
responsible decision yes
as if I’m the only one who doesn’t know He saves More
some
here he will be on 3 Well, also the field
C5 basically
there is still a chance to play
four knights even cling to an elephant
the sun three pawns again You know
such a response from the point of view
which is basically in position
where most likely
black will play on
I hope she's five
we still need to either deprive them of this
opportunity to keep more
cells It seems to me that maybe there was
already
does not quite clearly understand what the assessment is
this position 5 This could be exactly
that moment where
black
already felt well that white is like
maybe it's starting to go overboard
sometimes you wonder where it all went wrong
so yes At what point sometimes because
you make decisions like this
you overestimate your own positions or
doesn't matter
you continue to play for an advantage where you already
it's time to switch to the equation either
just objectively evaluate the position and
do Based on this, how to do
best codes
I don't know I'm not quite sure black
did everything they wanted after that
they were just changing it, it hurt the elephants
put a pawn at five and then carried out
yes They changed the bad bishop So well with
on the other hand, like yes you why me
I would change this elephant because
anyway Elizabeth she went on Friday
she gave her five and on the other hand
Well, there remains a weakness in black scientists
of course pawns C6 Yes, but if white
beat all DC here, it's probably already E5
there was no talk at all even at five
It turns out there won’t be exactly an idea. Well, okay
on the other hand, exactly in this
editors, this is not so bad anymore because
that it seems to me that consi barely but after
E5
maybe get Outpost 24
I don't know
elephant is already easy to raise one way
it’s bad if you manage to exchange it and I don’t know
most likely the position is equal
Of course, I don’t want to hit E5 right away and
that the pawn of us will also weaken again
can be
try to win bishop F8
[music]
maybe we should wait, well wait
for now decide to keep the voltage at
center
while we had a break and I managed
exchange a few words with the manger
sero-van and he said that he would come to them
Rex Sequeld's wife came to the studio
Ginny Ginny Ginny and she said that
it's actually starting to get very serious
competition between
husband because she decided that in the future
the cairns cup should reach a lot
more successful and stronger sex cup
interesting of course Remind ours too
listeners that baby filts are taking place
in August Yes it is probably simple
practically the strongest tournament in
world but it is held both in Classics and
Europe and the blitz are part of the chastura
most often it is taken there
participation
Well, when in fact We participate in
historical
even the tournament, that is, the primary sources
such a confrontation and Ginny actually
actually told us that when she
met Rex
40 years ago Let's see after all
let's touch on the topic
grand chastour this year
new tournaments will appear and even
I was surprised to see it will even be in Romania
tournament presents Previously
it reminds a little of the tennis system
Grand slam from which each participant
must play three tournaments and
results they get
the final where they play, in my opinion, 4 players they are in
each tournament they score points and
is being played out
in the system is also the Olympic system
in the beginning there will be a classic and in case
equality of points will be Rapid and Blitz
this year
I'm very glad that the tournament was preserved in
Paris every year with the French team
comment on this tournament in French
television which, in principle, is not entirely
common occurrence
[music]
and I hope that we will continue to do this too
this year and let me remind you that even in
France are broadcasting about this tournament
it's not Yes not so much not only direct
broadcast, that is, we work 6-7 hours a day
day and then we do daily
the program that is shown later
French television And sometimes in
most of the time not only late at night and
it's actually great that there are so many
tournaments this year I know that the feed
announced the Grand Prix and actually
this year's chess players' schedule will be
very complex and rich and of course
TV viewers and our viewers including
will be able to follow chess simply
all day long I don’t know if I’ll get it
they have time for anything else if
keep an eye on the clean level if
follow the women's grand prix series
tournaments it reminds me of a cartoon
I will alternate in the Soviet Union
oh they wore
quite innocent character and when the husband
once again returned home somewhere in
5-6 in the morning and he has a chessboard there
hidden somewhere is a chess magazine and
already at the door they look at him
completely menacing and screaming
I was in the chess club until 5
Can
something gives us the opportunity
watch a chess game
live around the clock and get intoxicated or
sharing is like a crazy passion
thanks to the internet these days it’s easy
every second every minute
good comment just can't stand it
I can't resist reading it
Elmira it’s interesting to listen to you, strong
chess player Charming lady cheerful
man, don’t spend your last emotions
if you stream on twitch would you subscribe
immediately Anastasia I have loved for a long time
Thank you very much Yes for your kind words
Alexandra has been luring me for a long time
Twitch I'm not entirely familiar with it yet
everyone
With modern technologies, it’s as if I
sometimes it's not as easy as it seems
do these things because
comments Yes this is one I really love
I really like to talk about chess
about your colleagues and how to invest here
namely to pay tribute to chess and speak
about them and closer chess at all to me
it seems like
Modern technologies help
also further popularizing himself on
that it’s as if I’m not quite capable yet and
it doesn't come so easy to me, that's why I
it seems that
this is where we work and
dedicate ourselves to something higher, that is
myself to me imperfectly well, as if about myself
I don't have to talk at all
I don’t think it’s really necessary. And you
tell me you actually met
with almost all the players in this
tournament you have a completely unique
experience is not only communication with them, but also you with
played with them You know what their character is You
you know their style of play I think it's like
since the knowledge that you missed
through yourself through your experience and with them
sharing in my opinion is very cool On the other hand
Yes, it can be very personal sometimes
and it’s not as easy as it would be during
tournament when you manage to touch on some
the desired topic or
and it seems to me that there are enough participants
sincerely share and respond to
questions and Well, this should also remain
such a holiday Yes, they may not be
daily show to make it pleasant
listen to this as if and yes, excuse me bye
I'm not quite ready for this yet
live streams can be
I will succeed in the future tense
play Blitz with friends Yes and
restore some kind of former Glory
I was very good at playing faces in Russia
now my head is practically nothing
understands I see how well
the younger generation is now playing
fast chess and
I need a little more work on this
to actually work I would also like to
note that at this tournament there is absolutely
A unique friendly atmosphere reigns
absolutely because when we arrived
Everyone was so obviously happy with each other
see the girls talking to each other
remembered some moments that is
in general and every day I see in batches
exchange is actually a myth that
a chess player is basically doomed to
loneliness he
gradually
[music]
as if the principle is being shaken
modern chess players chess players
they all are
people heroes of their time
they popularize how to start even
There are a lot of Magnus Kalsan himself
do to polarize chess and
everyone is a very cheerful person
their interests and
then maybe what the chess players are watching
somehow angry at each other or maybe like in
in other sports they tear your hair out
clothes on top of each other
[music]
reality and
and this may be
[music]
even lies some elegance
to the delicacy of chess players and
chess players and chess players who have
fundamentally completely different ethical
norms they relate to each other C
respect and
maybe in our time it is already
quite a rare occurrence, but
it's so nice to watch this
it always surprises me how
some chess ones
so friendly in real life
they sit down at the board and he’s just such a fighter
suddenly appear out of the blue
for example, I can say this to Valentina
kunina and harike were torn
always smiles before the party and then
turns into just very serious
rival
some kind of aggression in a good way
fighting sense that make me
reminds me of Kafka Yes Metamorphoses actually
in fact
he's quite scary to watch especially
when you're sitting opposite and I want
to say that we play with very often
Alexandra For example, training
parties even at home, well, sometimes it comes to that
just like this
positions where the game is on last
seconds and where everything is already decided
exactly
in this tenacity in this determination where
Sasha Gradually takes everything from me
figures
it really affects me
strongly I keep sitting at some point and
I think, how is this my best friend?
completely different people say but again no fork
noticed
It seems to me that we are about to have a break
so come on come on
let's say a few words
Let's see what happened in the game
Still, how many 5 minutes are left until
creep up quite see white white
after all, we held D4, which was kind of special
there were basically no ideas in this position
except
You see, she still thought about it
played 3 This is a very important positional
such a step
3S he's already five, I'm not sure what
Valentin is here D4 basically
interesting I want dcd horse B6 see
appeared four Yes the horse is already four
horse four why did it threaten or something
Why the king IZH-8 I don’t know. Here too
purely profilak maybe not maybe
she wanted to spend five I don't know
I don't know if it's even possible there
for a moment I don’t know what they’re up against
four I don’t know yet I can’t why not
horse C4 I like it
in principle, whites also have
you see the cage clings
4 watch the fourth broadcast zash-5 some
the move is the root of left-handers, and that is, she wanted
save I kind of always looked at F4
departure of the queens, that is, yes, clean with this
points of view yes preventive that is
she just wants to take our pawn yes yes
retained this opportunity
the king forced the horses already eight and now
let them multiply alone
three black will still beat three like that
and Valentin’s position is, in principle, very
good but 5 minutes left
unclear
Yes, how can we then transfer knight 8?
horse B6 I have some strange things to do
s8 yes Probably first
No, the youngsters are already on B8 Yes, in my opinion
go black, that's where it's eight and yes
sitting here always appears to me
such strange ideas I have eight B6 Yes
maybe eat it at E3 and translate
then the second knight on C4 and hold B4
already and play completely different
position is just about something yesterday
said yes to free up the field for
knight, that is, one piece and in fact
they're not so skinny
obvious yes
89 horse 8 some B6 Because I
I don’t see another transition of the horse and the horse is over
everyone costs enough for now
because four In principle you won’t go
Let's move on to the next game
kostyanuk satulandskih so what
happened
but then it seems to me that it’s already black
then you probably solved your problems if
were
after the elephant there is 6 she still went with
London three didn't beat on e6 Do we remember
stopped for a moment, black again
since they offered to stretch it, Queen D5 didn’t go
she went queen four yes
three I don’t like it, but also at least as much
nevertheless, in this position it is lost
no more tempo and here it is already
someone really carries
Scandinavian character is the party Yes
Queen he usually goes somewhere again
already five you know it seems like I really want it
punish blacks for such a Well Lost
number of tempos sometimes like this like
the challenge to a duel is just a gauntlet thrown down
absolutely not well how could you be so
it hurts and
Sometimes even like in poker Yes sometimes
some decisions seem perfect to you
irrational and as if
the knowledge that you are stupefied
accept
objectively not the strongest solutions
what exactly do you want to punish? Yes
rival for this impudence But on
in fact the most important thing is how to say
hold on
so it seems to me from this point of view
in principle, it makes it easier to protect
they still change 7 minutes every other day
in a position where there seem to be 7 minutes left
maybe well, too, as it were
makes the game in life a little easier
I didn’t see how to untie myself, that is
this king is therefore not at three maybe
at least not at three, it’s not the clearest, look, well
as if they are already black I think they have
absolutely normal position Yes and
typical Come on let's see what's going on
happened
[music]
8 as a matter of principle mine foresaw that is
White will be blown away along line C Well done
6 I like it at least Yes very good
in principle, white B4s are no longer a threat here
that C4 will always go black
this position is feminine of course to play
much easier. Maria has 8 minutes
left and I think it’s already possible
try to intercept at some point
yes at some point
Well, what if the white one just stands there for now?
nothing is possible or But it’s not so simple
do nothing actually three
how to translate it again where?
translate that maybe it needs to be led again
on F3 I don’t know which f13 I just don’t
I completely understand what cunnilingus is doing
it must either be regrouped, that is
one knight D2 go to defense too
pawns B3 and such a multifunctional 2
to save it on occasion
possibility of attacking E4 and defending
also C4 now black just too
blown down the line at some point They
will break through
That is, this position is very difficult
It's really time to intercept
play and quite justifiably Come on
let's see if you look at the time
then it will be completely unpleasant there
Muhariki happened to us for this as if
didn't put it she went the sun You again
assumed
So she decided after all
exchange a bishop for a knight because
there were a lot of threats in this
positions as if this makes it easier in principle
and choice and whites
nine six
that is
restored material collection
very chaotic
Let's see what it really is
set a trap Now if 3 Come on
I'll just show the functions one yes then
will have to show only I will never
I see this one
there are immediately beautiful
as if it were completely primitive to sit down a pawn
we probably knight D5 after all Yes it is necessary
go to five
Well yes yes
I don't know I can't track down at all
party
really look at the board it's worth it
doesn’t yawn anything, here’s the first thing you need right away
watch everything take And what actually happened
Let's see Completely natural
understand the desire of whites, that is, to exchange
this crazy knee D4 and they are now
probably already attacked, take the pawn all three
horse, that is, a horse and attacked idea
completely simple
and attacked D4 from the other side of the knight
this queen 2 and
Just
the easiest
but there was absolutely no
crazy idea from the horse in 3 Well I don't know
here or not, it’s still there
No no no I already I already changed the horse
Yes
No let's see then
two and
maybe 666
Rook 5 she wants to transfer Simply to
equal endgame Let's see
again
but still keep pawn C or
it's not enough anymore, look at it after all
the cells are good
but she has a very active figure
Well, let’s say how did they go? Yes, they beat
This is a completely forced option
again maybe even Rook alone No
you see, instead of 6 there was nothing more
again I don't know
OK
[music]
have there been any changes or
in fact, here she is already playing more
in her style she spent E5 in 4 see
how would she
[music]
maneuver between such positional
idea AND
dynamic solutions in principle F4
she also retains the possibility
attack when you like I already have a position
I don’t know black people, maybe there’s nothing in it
no longer, but compared to the one that
was actually just completely Yes
very good healthy position Yes what
do Well, that's it, I'm like four what now
you can't do it on horseback at four
on the other hand, look here again
what diagonal opened for white
elephant for one if four then that is
bad move
I'll show you
Well, you see in this position the bishop F4
3 probably yes and
How to decide where to put an elephant
sometimes I’m also afraid to put it in color
note that's when the elephant is on one
maybe not entirely. It's certainly scary.
And
solution Well look now 3 how
white will be untied
how can it be
here is the moon
it is very important to exchange Now this
there are six elephants but leave it for now
this bunch and look at the white ones
saved is weakness five well
they're probably not on the other side
they will put the knight on D4, that is, this one too
Yes
most likely equal position
I think now is the time to do
a short break after which we
Let's go back and watch the endings
the party will follow the color I would
you don't follow at all
[music]
dear chess lovers, those who remain
with us at this late hour, welcome
welcome back to our studio and
there is a guest and Mikhail Khodorkovsky
vice president fide president
Garikasparov Charitable Foundation and
former women's national team captain
USA
Hello again Mikhail, we are glad to see you
Hello again to our studio and I
I understand that you came with interesting
there will be several news today
interesting announcements I think we
we can ask for the gram chastura schedule
which we have already seen before would be
it would be great if they showed it again
here it is again in all its glory Yes, I am
Today
I act as
representative of Gran Chistor
all previous
titles that I
listed Yes, not today a little
step aside because today
the day when gram is clean
announced the participants
2019 season
We are very pleased that
All
best chess players in the world
accepted the invitation except
Vladimir Kamenik who announced his
cessation of professional chess
tournament activities Although We hope
that maybe he will accept the invitation
we will play in one of the tournaments
rapid chess and blitz
we will have 5 like you
you see with the schedule we have increased
number of tournaments up to 8
in rapid chess and the public and two in
classical system and
the final tournament is already the finalists
four finalists based on results
season will meet in London for
title of winner of the Grand Hour Tour
We have also increased the number of participants
from 9 to 12 and thus we have
increase in the number of participants as in
the main tour and among those who will
invited
like Vile cards and
this this year out of five tournaments
which will directly
in quick and chess and blitz
those who participate in the Tour they will have to
play 3 out of 5, that is, according to the system
qualification system The final will be
consist of two classic tournaments and
three rapid and blitz chess tournaments
accordingly, participants will choose
coordination with management
What tournaments are they
will take part
one of the main events of course is
that world champion Magnus Carlson
returns
as a member of the Grand Chistura
full format and will participate in
two classic three
chess tournaments
didn't take part I think it was
related to the match in first place Yes
of course it is difficult for him to take part in
the year he must defend his title
Although he participated in
previous years
both as a participant in a full tour and as
participant
one or two rapids and a blitz this
once he accepted
invitation and will participate as
full participant in all of Torah
And as I said, all the presenters
the chess players have signed contracts and have already
starting from the tournament which will take place in
Africa
we have increased not only the number
tournaments and participants but also the range
actions
geography
America has expanded to all continents
Asia Africa Europe and for the first time in history
The world's leading chess players will visit
African Continent will play there
tournament This is what I hope it will be
have a huge resonance and in addition it
will influence the development of chess in Africa
undoubtedly
huge push
which is typical, here we begin
first tournament in
Africa directly
and the last tournament will be in Kolkata
And this is also new
the place where the first tournament will take place
times They held in November
themselves and they with great
enthusiasm
are also included in the Grand chestura system
our new places are Bucharest and Zagreb
Elmira was very surprised
Bucharest will
yes, that is, our geography is expanding
even within Europe
if we only had Paris and London then
We
moving towards Eastern Europe
Bucharest so we are very happy about that
what we have achieved in a short time
expand both geography and prize fund
increased to 1 million 750 thousand
which is probably the largest
prize fund probably in the entire history
in the field of tournaments and therefore
sponsors
interested and we have signed an agreement
with the company that will deal
directly
branding and output of our
grand tours to higher level in
including on television
very good
for all viewers
will move to a French-speaking country in Paris
Yes, and it seems to me that it’s just huge
gift to all chess players and all amateurs
Check for chess lovers
In fact
Let's return now to the women's tournament
briefly wanted to say what's wrong
Vladimir Kramnik
ended his career and his place
his place became vacant and Sergei took his place
Karjakin is also a Russian chess player
which was the next rated and
thus the number of Russian
chess players
then what happened during this time we are somewhere
stopped Oh, they haven't been there for a long time
looked at this game somewhere here like this
Where Valentina transferred her C4 channel
it became clear that black had probably decided
your problems, but at this time you're awesome
there was little time left at the moment
It's not so bad anymore 4 minutes almost 5
minutes versus six
Well, in fact, Black's position is already
it was better after that I went to C4 then
undoubtedly
position
strategic lost for white
because the king is exposed to the pawn
advanced there is no movement
There is practically no Counter game If
If you look at the configuration they are
look like checkers except pawns except
pawns as many as 5 bishops on G2 which rests
in general it has no
life
and chances to enter the game then everything else
stand here, look, pawn B2 is multiplying
one Rook D2 Queen 2 Checkers
structure Meanwhile, black in this
time actually no longer has a position
meanings because absolutely clear
scientists game plan
[music]
implementation
heavy artillery
after this everything will collapse
weakness
royal flag
weak rush D4 now only one more
let down
So
somehow Valentina Gunina still managed
at some point outplay your opponent
that is, this is the idea because
whites had no clear plan what to do
further, that is, well, the horse is on E1
jumping to F3 means giving up a pawn
as much as 5
moving the F4 pawn is a weakening
G3 pawns as a result
with maneuvered through field E7
going to
queenside and
the structure is generally falling apart no
protection damn
so now
high understanding
there were a lot of elephants
[music]
very difficult position
3 already move lost position Yes if
the knight will take two then Rook B is one
step and so on General position Of course
if some are desperate, then Rook beats
B5 Rook will take v5d G2 and 2 goes to B8
also a hopeless position
So
I think this game will end
very soon now
spectators
I honestly can't answer this
the question is because the office is doing this
American Chess Federation
How many
I understand that the leading chess players
will most likely have a similar composition as
at the Olympics or there will be some
I think there will be big changes
the changes are good, it’s clear what Nazis should do
for some reason I couldn't accept it
participation She won't participate by the way
and in
defend your title as American Champion
Yes, this is already known and she did not accept
invitation to the team
as far as I understand, but you can do it
ask Irina Joanne if they
planning to go
I know they won't go either
will play in the American Championship
which starts literally in
three days after the end of the team
world championship
Most likely Most likely both teams
will be youthful I see
prepare a new shift for the future Yes but
I can't
to say categorically and precisely because
this is handled directly by the office
Federations and they coordinate this with
the players will tell me that there is one more
the game is over we can see on
screens, Mariy Sipak played a draw with
female Abdumalik Although Abdumalik was
it's quite a promising position
had, in general, throughout the entire party
good position and everything was on time
ok but when the figures change
the king is open
of course the party
now let's say we return somewhere to
moment approximately when they exchanged
Verdika I would rather go back to the moment
when queens weren't the same size
you know 4 our 5
Here it is, yes, it’s like move 4
again here
white
they play slowly and it’s unclear what
is happening
in this position let's play not C6
How Anya played play knight C6 give
this pawn
fight for the initiative
Well done 8
should probably run away
and the second Rook needs 8
classical
classic theme
yes sacrifice pawn sacrifice for the initiative on
book
And
agree that in this position there is great
It seems to me that the scientists have a positional advantage
there if the elephant still moves to F6
And
here whites need to find a chance
decided she was better
will keep this pawn
these cavalry 6 are still worth better
White still has the opportunity to play more
calmly
F1 is always difficult but nevertheless it is
need to use a more active game
Yesterday I said that we need to play with pieces
This case doesn’t even pay attention
Please note that pawn 7 is in this position
plays absolutely no role anymore
Moreover, it interferes with the development of the rook
Before we go for a very short
break look here is the final position
which is now on the board and somehow
evaluate it before coming to the studio
will come need to drive And these are ours
party comments
How to assess the current situation
I don't know, it's just that blacks don't care
better position
option today actually plays on
I think so too
some specific some specific
Human
and what after that
happened because
little bone too, not much time
left
last seconds
in fact there are literally three left
progress then control and
I think we'll leave very quickly now
literally 20 seconds for advertising and
Let's come back here Thank you very much
announcement for the entire chess world and
We are waiting for you Tomorrow I hope you too
You will definitely find time
[music]
and here we are back with us on the
our guest will just rot
tied against Harry Kenternov
Thank you, but it's because you came to us
to the studio we are very glad to see you here
there was a very interesting game today but
before we get to it, I wanted to
ask you about what kind of
here is the feeling, here we are finally all
We got to Saint Louis and I think many
yours
fans were worried that you would get there
here or not at all Tell me about it
something happened Hello everyone Yes, come on
there were problems
I just received it in the evening
just yesterday
it turned out to be such a bad batch Well
and today
everything went more cheerfully but in fact I
I know that you came after all
a couple of days before the start of the tournament and
even held a session for local girls
Maybe you can tell me about this I only saw
photos I think everything went smoothly
excellent in general and such an atmosphere
everyone loves chess
in America it’s generally the capital, as I understand it
the capital is why everyone is like that
respect
I enjoyed watching the broadcasts
look see in detail literally the hall
games and now be there to play what
you can say there is some even me
anyway I eat to
concentrated on my fingers therefore
after
rest
Okay, let's go back to the desk, that is
it turned out very interesting today I
I think you surprised your opponent after all
Well, I’m just Andrey somehow I didn’t know three
I don’t know why Well, not three I watched more
Here
Is it possible to do this Flip It doesn’t work
it turns out yes, I understand what’s wrong with you
damn it's easier yesterday I tried too
and then somehow they try to just condo
strength roots shies How to put it like this
a lot of fingers just after the separation
I don't know, I'm just not like that at all
I balanced at all
I should feel myself in such positions
like a fish in water No, that's what you are too
you probably like to get it sometimes
[music]
and at 4 I think so
maybe the flowers here I don’t know are like this
I looked at these options I don’t know yet
this knights 5 straight away somehow yes yes
And here
I looked at all these options, but no
I think there's nothing
That's why
she want
so I think I should play right away
that's why I went like this
just wondering
here are the children again Yes here she is
I could of course
5 B And these five are also like this
it seems unclear I don’t know maybe I have
It’s already good here
Well, I think she just won’t have time
block yours with a pawn
I watched this
if so they have 4 Well yes yes here
I have something, well if it’s simple
Slomitria will go here, I didn’t find it
Nothing
I don’t know, the pawn at least wants to
[music]
then here I went to hell 5 beats
owns 3 though
I think there's a curse word there
if not if H6 Just the sun 5 I'll go and
I think it's fire at three at once
I think it's a spoon
[music]
I succeeded
after all
[music]
behind the stage
in the Production Studio I don’t even know anymore
How in Russian would it really be?
very convenient to watch all the games
on the screen they are installed everywhere in
chess club in somnus this building is on
really just incredible
where any
chess amateur observer can
keep track of all parties on any
actually the floor of the chess club and that’s it
the audience here has done a lot for them
cute Very nice so much
enjoying chess chess yeah come on
let's see what happened after all
see I'm looking at the position that
originated in the party Irina Krush and Bunina
Valentina I slightly forgot I was watching
also for the color stage on
Valentine's screen is very, very
acted calmly in her color note
the position you see was quite easy
play black even leaving yourself 5
minutes
when this moment of the window 3 he too
said, apparently we’ll have to get better already three
yes but still
inevitably yes And how much in principle
Fine
Valentina carried out this plan, that is
quite successfully to which I said yes
She would bring 4 actually Well she
took it to a slightly different edition
weak rush B2 she said
Whites completely failed
defense in fact here is an elephant even two
see how much he
it’s still bad in such positions yes And
here already even when She succeeded already in
the principle of exchanging the weakened field E4
no need to sacrifice quality
Already so a little desperate
threat horse G6
[music]
Elmira What do you think are the chances?
White have some way to escape or have a chance
there are simply no theoretical ones
because on
any move in principle will follow sooner
Total
in two I don’t see how anyone can protect themselves from
mat
No it's actually I think it's Irina
She gave up, she seemed to get along after two
I actually froze the picture Yes
was done by the king already three I just don't
I see. Well, what to do after two
There are practically no mating threats to White
create Because with the queen 8 That is
when as soon as Fedya moves away from defense
But in other way
What can I do Queen E3 go I don’t know
even let's say yes Well yes how can it be
save some Well, that is, there is no queen
2 moves now no Well at least queens 2 in
in principle, it translates perfectly
the endgame is won, that is, there is a queen
two in two-deli two The whole thing is 94 Well
maybe two hearts are enough
it's really sad here Yes, any move
leads to victory for black Uh-huh
We'll see
Zatonskih that is how it ended we
with Mikhail Adorkovsky we watched there
no And when it’s already a pawn
I watched this one too
on the screen
the heaviest was the color of the notes. It seems to me not
the moves were so easy in this position
because it was literally already there
reminded me a little
ten
the plane was able to visit the cockpit from
pilots to land the flight
Paris Berlin and When the Altitude Drops
the sensors tell you about this
it turns out when it’s two thousand meters
one and a half thousand meters thousand meters and
it's all done like this
in a terrible voice he reminded me of this
approximately this situation where I already found 5
seconds 4 seconds 3 seconds literally on
there were some hours left I don’t know but
for a fraction of a second they are at some point me too
I think Anya tried to play for Victory but
but not me
as they say, it seems to me that Sasha did it too
just the only moves so as not to
get a lost position
that is, the plane was landed successfully
coped with this task
after all, it may be with the Blacks
I don’t know, maybe there were more chances in
basically as the fight progresses You see she
Anya went through a bad position and
in principle, if there is an opportunity to catch on Well
yes, this one is already asking for something like this
unusual idea also reminds me of
party Timon Shortyman where at weakening
there were weak Black King and White King
went through there with a full board of pieces
at 6 and just set it, well, sort of
created a mat threat of course
the white ones dragged through by ramming, that is,
four H5
such an opportunity is easy to build
you're actually shedding it's okay now
and save
some specific game needs to be defended
active Basically as
demonstrated by Alexandra And in fact
in fact This is an interesting method of protection Mikhail
showed a very interesting idea which
which we passed by in our debut
here he is of course
proposed to completely catch the move on
sleepy 4 go here just consul
6 give up a pawn yes And this is by the way
standard victim it seems to me
standard day but I don't seem to
I agreed with the knight's move at 3, here I am
I don’t like it I think this is the beginning
problems Actually in White's position
which this did not foretell at all
position
I don't like what happened at all
this part is such an unusual tango
and unexpectedly, basically black after
the exchange queen received a better position
I think it was quite easy for them
White may also play by inertia
again Black played for an advantage
were colored type
natural result
Turns out there's only one batch left
what happened in the party or the singer Yeah
exactly, even though I don’t quite understand
Yeah let's go back
Whenever I turn away they are still playing Yes
but it’s worth not turning away or from equal
positions
Magic wand
gave a pawn where we will return to what
moment Let's see these maybe yes
just understand how the character has changed
fight, remember G3 I said that the cat
Quite naturally it was already done
five But it seems to me
four Yes and
as it was
would be one
yes it catches right away 6 maybe right away
You won’t go to such a range either Yes
I would like to simplify the position again
thereby facilitating protection in
in principle it seems to me no maybe not
it was worth changing these elephants I don’t know but
this is a certain human decision I
In general, it’s hard to blame me for this
won't rise
of course you want me so much
natural solution Let's see
as if at six And what happened Oh how
you see, that is, well
it turned out to be such an Outpost on D4
cling and understand Look at the icon
left he also weakened, that is, field B6 and
Rook Apparently it just maybe, well, sort of
we combine many threats in this position
White apparently won a pawn
I would like how it was in principle
played this position She gradually
she was strengthened look at all the figures now
are worth
in principle, in optimal positions such
on the cells and the king 2 she got rid of
from potential [ __ ] and perhaps from
Well, I don’t know any fabulous mattes
threats that could arise our three
Of course I don't know either
[music]
such a childish fantasy of mine
What are all the same in this position before
useful move Not entirely clear and very
I just managed to play
or went and 4 as if such an active move
version 3 I like the ending
So what should we do now?
can save
nothing can be unloaded yet
I don't know if
7 was done maybe she was afraid that
there is this idea after all, taking it to 5
Queen D8 to pick up on D7 That is, how would I
not quite sure, how could it be
probably eight
Yes, you see, it means taking the pawn after all
you can’t Well, that is, you have to look Well
let's say I don't know any move and
see what happens on
five and there’s no way after all
bring lodges via B1 to B8 what’s there
the idea is already starting, well, there are four queens
There is
let's say if we go
you need to make a useful move no even five
weakens very much I don’t know
useful Unfortunately
can't leave
[music]
F6 maybe that's the issue F3 later
again in fact there may be this
there was a threat just yes I'm completely with
I agree with you again very hard
protect Yes, there are no more cells at all
I think you see it from the other side
maybe it's a slight weakening
Let's watch
just go A4
then you would give me four square
I see Probably four FSB four That
Yes, I'm so unloaded actually
Maybe I myself am not threatening anything
I know how
take four
the position just starts to fall apart to me
seems Elizabeth Exactly right
seems to be no longer weakening
your position So what happened
[music]
By the way
still exchange
[music]
kuni 6 rook and 6 yes
Even though you understand
position you even having exchanged this horse
White's position is still it
as if it were preferable, it’s still lighter
play in black's position you see how
the all-grown king is weakened in principle in
such positions are very important
the position of the king but still the king is on
G2 feels calmer Yes comfortable
Let's say this again, it's still material
balance is maintained but pressure
pressure A4
I think
a little bit
Hello today technical problems
day technical problems occur
problems with sound too
and with electricity
And in general it became somehow cold in
San Fluise And actually even a little
It's cool in the studio, so I have to
drink hot coffee keep warm
[music]
the weather here has changed a lot Yes
Elmira, when you arrived they said it was
even somewhere plus 15 and today it seems
it's already closer to zero and the wind and rain
how the British switched to weather
and but that is, the temperature amplitude
I was completely amazed I flew to
I got a policy for literally a day
it was -36
the next day it became minus 10 and the next
day just literally plus two arrived
in a dream there was departure
minus 56 the next day it was 15 then
because
strange, so natural
why is there only one heart and do you remember these
He asked whether whites have a chance to
the rescue
come on wait what's going on
and that is, maybe the whites have
the opportunity to transfer to such
endgamekonev 8
beat on C1 here there is a walk
Is it like it's holding on You know
just easy Yes, wait and believe Yes
wait, maybe there will be a punch right away
wait maybe wait there let me
I'll take a look
and save this opportunity if you take
then let's just say maybe or
pawn and try to build I don’t know
does such strength last?
the pawn falls on d512
4 then I'm six
and but in principle I’m not quite yet Well,
quite possible Yes I wow That's it
will untie if this is really what it is
Now comes wait let's see
first let's be careful no wait for me
it seems one that is the end of eight
king eight eight
back back
here, wait, maybe this is it
let's go three now happening
you know at some point the brains just
turns off it seems that any move
wins and
and you literally start playing with your hand
I can’t imagine the white one hasn’t been made yet
move I think Irina crash is rechecking
all these options are most likely yes she is
double-checks what's happening on horse 8
horse 6 because
This is the first line, in principle, it seems to me
And
The abacus is actually not that much here anymore
because it actually forces you
make the only moves
this will of course be a very hard blow for
[ __ ] off if she doesn't win this position
because of course it's great
understands that there was absolutely no
won
well you understand this on the other hand
she played the party very hard despite
to the fact that it is very slow and basically
good enough
She played Blizzard Spire she just
outplayed
[music]
after two turns he rushes just straight into
the eyes actually
What am I, what could be something?
missed it here but it might be good
horse 6 Wait again
ok yes King King same 8 Come on
Let's see for sure It's definitely here
we watched the king 4
anyway compared to that
position we can take at least a pawn
Is it possible to wait shorter than 4
because I
looked ahead
[music]
the king is alive Well of course that's why Yes
didn't watch it Why
owning F2, probably yes. But we, in general, we
tired too
In fact, you just take away
opportunity to defend yourself and then quickly
everything is clear that there is no move for the queen
4.3 Let's take a look here again because
maybe there are some others
purely
technical difficulties and technical
there are always difficulties yes yes of course even
You know
So maybe go to the endgame already
[music]
here
Of course I don't want that
two
so Well, that’s cool and then we’ll be shorter for me
this seems like dancing
in fact, at least there is one
the opportunity is much better than that
which is worth Let's see and here
I have some, well, let's go get some clothes
we'll show you
what else do we see there transition to the endgame
won two is actually a move to be
maybe she didn’t notice this move
because he owns this exactly
she actually stopped
two because we are absolutely not
checked take didn't check let's
look what should be there
rearrangement is actually your heart
two Yes, she just doesn’t leave any
chances and most likely Valentine because
Well, she didn’t notice this and the party
of course what we thought happened
there were six horses to take
now here And now I don't see how
you see now it’s already moving into the endgame
it doesn't work out because you maybe
is it even possible
Absolutely crazy move on the connection
make four how interesting
I don't know, I'm also a king
so much It seems so to me Yes I am
I thought what an interesting thing this is
position Yes, I don’t know how, well, Rook F2
how is it all and I watched the king is
thenback
Yes, now you can’t, by the way, you can No, really
beautiful Let's show it anyway
viewers because F6
the position actually arises and
You see, he might even be alive, and so
this idea in five is easy to fix and
chicken defends the pawn on D4 That is, I don’t
I see how to proceed
May be
[music]
shki
and somehow getting around the king also seems to me
dangerous
Well done one
himself
if there is any idea for sweets 4 so
then you no longer cling to the pawn
Then I'll just walk king three
no Let's go back Yes this is it wait 4 king
same 3 and some move for example king g8
let's say wait You see maybe Well
then the King is already three and we don’t let him in
field H4 may not be worth it, of course, but
just out of interest, in principle how much
there are interesting ideas in chess
positions because I don't really see
in fact
this is of course a typical example, only three yes
a typical example of how impossible
relax at any moment and I don't
I think this is certainly the case when
Valentina relaxed, but here's one move
may miss trees completely
change position rating I think she
I'm probably just tired
Wait, what's going on here again?
something again something was placed I don’t know
I just don’t understand what’s going on anymore
I'm not entirely sure I think it's just
Valya thinks now after the horse is not six
So she was thinking
you see I just don't have
now I have
there was a completely different position what was what
came one king same 4d1 queen in 3 yes
and maybe this is the very last one
editorial office profitable
I suggest you take another look
literally with an eye on the party Although they found it
Elizabeth because she should come to us
Alexander Kosteniuk is also a world champion and
tell us about what happened today
their parties with the Zatonsky I think that
great opportunity to find out for yourself
what happened
prepared All our thoughts are on
really it was just great
this stage of the game
note She played very well and the queens
that is, she and
goes over
she went 4 maybe it was decisive
mistake because it's like the last one
there are already a lot of cells and B4 and the pawn itself
hanging
which
you explained why you don’t need to do it
hard
It’s hard, my hand won’t rise at all
disgrace anyone for such things
it is very difficult to defend in such positions
Look, in principle, a-and weak blacks
fields
white
always seems to be eyeing the pawn
C6 Black has so much weakness, but it seems
as if, in principle, after leaving the opening
and after the exchange you write to structures well
after the exchange of pawns in the center it seems that
Well, you're such an optical illusion Yes
Black's passed pawn is probably five on
in fact, this could be the structure
D5 C6 Right at this moment
fixed pawn five she
it’s very beneficial for white they seem to have much
the space is bigger and so black
weak white fields it seems to me this
the stage of the party was led simply
immaculately worth it
explain why black In the end they gave it away
moved this pawn to 4
[music]
If I am not mistaken
probably protect this pawn after the queen
[music]
White could afford and the queen in
how can there still be after the queen at 6
keep getting along 8 or then maybe
Rook H6 wait Rook A8
eight are breeding
Is it possible to use this somehow?
you're in a hurry 4 basically she was to me
it seems you can
In fact
but very often after the greenhouse is like this
Hope during the transition that you can find
sometimes sometimes there are two or three pawns missing
eternal step This is practically good
chance but here Unfortunately, in principle
so
for some eternal step And so it was as if
carried out this plan H5 I really
liked
is really created and
after 6 I can’t even see Well, what should I do?
like physics 3 What happens on FS D3
now there's a threat to go firsha to everyone probably
this pawn and move yours of course
on physical D3 maybe just then already
again Yes, it can just change, but what the hell
will go distantly
[music]
then Well, the simplest move maybe
it's completely acceptable to try and I'll try
I think maybe
give some nuance through A7 wool
step I don’t know I need to think about it Yes
let's say version 7
where I just liked you know what sometimes
there are three options
Now I really like it better
exactly what Elmira was talking about
you can try at some point
active game score find some kind of eternal
step
[music]
Wait wait, I'm already very tired too
then after all, no, it’s written at all
I didn't like it either
It seems to me that it was preserved, that is, when
in short 4 I still wanted to go to G3 but
on firmem I
May be
king 5 king yes let's hold on
the primary Shah will not be there
I don't know at 4:00
more likely
Yes
I ran away. Let's go back to
Alexandra Kosteniuk's party Maybe
she gives us
spend a couple of minutes in the interview
we'll be back
[music]
version of the whole
teams
lacks
[music]
didn't ask
Welcome to our studio with us
Alexandra Kosteniuk
Alexander was absolutely perfect today
some unusual opening stage
party Tell us a little Yes if only
Briefly speaking
it didn’t work out I don’t know why not move 4
was unknown Unfortunately, well you
you know actually it seems to me
that it is the strongest who wants position
really
aware but unfortunately during the game I
wasn't aware but actually we
analyzed during the party as if
too
thought maybe Anya was a friend of Zaton
was with it
apparently a strong move because here, well
how to walk king F1 entrance of course
which you don’t want to do because
I want to castle normally but after
kont- it's two just at night everything is very
changes anyway I thought about going this way and
here go the king alone
Well, I don’t know why I didn’t believe it. I’m like that
yes it looks very much like a bargaining chip
Yes
I don’t really want to go to French
understood in short
decided Well, yes, if he is the strongest for that
so that it is equal to extremely and three
maybe Well, I don’t know No, let’s just
game progress Yes
went as if at five strong very move uh
I'll go back first
makes such moves in the spirit of the position here
a lot of moves in the spirit of the position but first I
I'm glad that I'm here Hmm, just what?
it turns out property Well, it’s simple and
somehow I didn’t even see anything
version 4 Well, here too, yes somehow it is necessary
look and some exchanges bishops in 4 but
there also seems to be nothing special there, maybe
even castle or eat Probably
first Yes, as if in 3gf castle Me
it seems that it's absolutely true that the elephant went
no time right but then I of course
it's terrible here like this to me
liked it
question
it does need to remind me a little
Where is the connection with this Scandinavian party?
constantly they have to go back the knife I
I understand what the computer shows
is that yes, apparently Austria
you understand you need something Yes
rebuild
it seemed slow but still
how to walk like that And why are you
considered
that is, I liked you
it seemed like it was very slow here
nothing but I guess I have a question
there is simply nothing here, but
after H3 there is probably some kind of position
complex persists Yes after the horse in
Streaming me is probably worse already Yes
most likely four there she just could
giving up a pawn is not the worst question
it worked out
six are probably just already there for Victory
black can somehow play with the king F1
I never left the debut. I don’t know or
this man is eight C6 I already
I was happy because I understood here
what is no shook for four too
These are alarm bells and we need to urgently
try to equalize somehow and therefore
Percy five for me for happiness was well with
on the other hand, I understood that I had everything
even a little worse because the king is not
already switched yes switched
two plans Well, that is, I wanted to go
of course Just B3
king barely Maybe, but I decided that
with a knight on D4 it’s more interesting because
that I wanted to intercept everything somewhere for me
it seemed like he was getting younger here D8 no move
didn't like it I thought I was very
much stronger because well F6 somewhere
on horseback 6 Fe Yes, sometimes there are ideas
that is, Rook F8 It seems to me that
eliminates all questions about the advantage
black mathematics she saved
I don’t know the possibilities, there’s some idea there
again and four here it seems to me
much more important than the idea of ​​opening the line
Yes, since I have a king in F1, that’s all
and it’s still there, uh, and I’m not here
I know it’s already time for some reason
very little And I went at four But I
yawned just here I was getting ready
go
sun four Well, suddenly I saw that
one end
didn't like it
with this pawn and it is simply better Therefore
I decided that
there is such a move here I’m not quite
I call
that is, somehow here I understood
which most likely seems to be more accurate
Well done 4 Well, any elephant I think
after all, white is more dangerous to change hands
Why didn't I come here I can't understand
scared The Lion King 8 Maybe but
there's at least 7 here, I don't know why it's not here
I went because this is the endgame but I
still without a pawn but I'm threatening Rook and 8 yes
and I threatened Diapa-7, that is, I am a pawn
I'm acting out
what am I afraid of
maybe I forgot
at Korolev 8 I forgot that Ladyan Yes
interval
I went to do nothing as if it was 3 o’clock
I liked it
but here too it’s just minutes on the clock
and before I had time to count, I realized that
need to move Rook D1
I thought she was walking around here again
but also A4
there was no longer enough time to extend
and in general, these two are missing
there were a lot of difficult opportunities
options And the last thing I saw was
watched this during the color stage
parties on screen
in the last seconds I can't even get my hands on it
Already shaking
at some point I don't know I really
I liked this one, it’s so clean
dynamic she could go to hell
show on after the same six already
didn't like it
of course but
I think after already but after and again
the position probably remains unpleasant
but I have some kind of Contra literally 5
suddenly this power can be such that with
on the other hand, your rival is after all
after, well, like the last 20 moves
still plays for literally 30 seconds
time the whole batch Well, that is, the whole color
I had the sheet music but she still has it
I thought about it already in the last stage of the party Well
as if she also had very little
time tension is still said
she had much more time than
me, well, that is, I made a couple of moves
once every five seconds, but of course here
her position is much more pleasant, it’s unlikely
maybe something yawns Yes, there’s a price here
there is a lot of movement and more
Congratulations on your miraculous rescue
They themselves created the problems, they themselves gave them
decided
[music]
Explorer
How come you haven't fallen asleep there yet?
in distant Russia in cold Europe yes
In Ukraine
in Kazakhstan in Kazakhstan not at all
I can’t imagine already earlier
morning seems to me to be the opposite amount
viewers because someone is waking up
our broadcast Great stay with us on
we actually found out what happened
somehow they found it, they will definitely come to us
to the studio and we'll see We tried before
analyze Well, just a couple of moves
she took the pawn on seven and even
shahmala That is, she actually went
again six to get rid of even
maybe a countdown so as not to count
physical step in principle actually
From a practical point of view, it seems very
the right decision, what should I do?
and I just chose the one you said
here to the same position
she actually gave
Defended a pawn
and defended herself from the Shah That is, in principle
well deserved victory you know sometimes
That's what you think
again happened in this pattern like
I think so
such an illustrative example where B
basically white just outplayed
better at some point
yes, in principle, this is a party where
which deserves a home analysis
Especially I think from the outside or
to really understand what
moment everything went awry if I didn’t
so easy it seems like she would have exchanged it
his bad elephant changed as if
spent the typical money again
[music]
weaknesses and weakness
from this point of view, the party seems to be
Black they played all the planned moves All
ideas and played quite actively but in
As a result, we simply ended up with a broken
trough and was very well implemented
really interesting to know how
she actually looked at this whole position
Do you remember there were a few on
critical moments she went C5 to one
moment
it was such a controversial decision
motivate yes That is, you can find out
why is it probably not on the other side?
Maybe she decided again in this
positions
what she might have foreseen or what
as if on C5, that is, there will be black
spend and five and cunnilingus two that is
such a plan, again, well, a standard move
I don’t know the position of moving the knight either to D4
this is how it probably stands at this moment
warm up and maybe some other you
can you tell me
probably again
Very
ok she
I'm not entirely sure with this plan
at some point you see they still said
black fields maybe
I didn't want to either
so that there are as many white cells as they are
F4 to D4 but maybe you need a brand
there was no way to get attached to the C5 chip
I know you know
it's hard to say it's hard to say of course
especially now when
Let's watch
happens in the endgame Irina Krush and
Valentina Gunina
8 was the end 6 yes, can you imagine it?
the option that, in principle, we
they donated you, they came and asked
nine two and this is at least 62 actually
in fact, most likely from afar it’s not at all
obvious
first we passed D2 and then finally
noticed F2 threats
is located first
tired
Nervous tension is taking its toll during this
Of course, mistakes are being made here
save the opportunity
Yes, I suggested moving 2 earlier
still stronger I will drive 4 queens to 5 and
most likely Valentina didn’t see it
actually two Well, that is, or even
this maneuver is what df2 and queen F5 here
that's why we got this endgame
in fact, I haven’t exchanged it here
queens She decided to go continue No
she exchanged the queen, which means for squares in
three Yes, so that this doesn’t happen
wonderful yes indeed very
interesting but uh
[music]
White has resources even in this management
or enough to do king
was tied to pawn defense Already seven in
in any case, that is, it would be necessary
how to change g74 again as
happened in the park
I think that's enough anyway
what now is it in case blacks are extra
exchanges for the knight and pawn but this
probably not enough to
fight for victory which is now certain
here it’s just probably 5 we can go
H6 I don't know with a threat to everyone I don't even know
most likely not so everything may not be
it's so simple but you have to try
exchange for the last pawns and simplify
position and let's go back to the party then
it was theirs it was our bike against
Elizabeth because it was just now
she should fit
and It was very soon when ours was led
will appear in our studio and tell you
finally let us know what she was thinking
during the game What are the plans and what
made decisions At what moments
we will come to a position that we have repeatedly
showed with Elmira Skripsinka
and here we are again in the studio so cut
Krivchenko just won too
Elizabeths Hello Bela Dobro
welcome to us for the first time you are in our studio
of course we'll watch the game Tell us about
your impressions of the tournament then how
you are playing here
that El chooses Which of the schemes to play and
at some point she decided to go to
this one A6
and 6 so that you know this moment here
Or was this all quite new for you?
Yes that's all
four then
[music]
first question
have you considered the possibility
put in
45 I liked it and the horse
liked
[laughter]
[music]
Let's see a little now
there are only opportunities at every turn
in fact, that is, as if I was striving
after all, you want a more closed position
to stay now
what can you say about this plan?
which was spent black, that is, really
this whole Strategy was Wrong or
somewhere then a mistake was made
I think it's
weakens
I thought the sun was four then
a little different story
[music]
this is where it gets interesting
figures
What moment do you think somewhere
something went wrong black that is
it seems like they did the right thing
things they wanted to do changed again
black-field elephants but
when there were only
what moment that is, let's say maybe
can you tell me
already when they exchanged Yes
changed here
[music]
ran away there
such a possibility
I don't know
I was watching something like this
but even if there is an extra pawn
the chances are higher
[music]
need to be careful
have to go back
there is no pawn but there is some activity
already on the screen
because
there are no blacks
Well, yes, here, too, cinnamon clearly saw that
escaped all the eternal Shahs
There was no hope left
Are you satisfied with your results?
this moment
more
[music]
arrived a few days before the start
I saw the tournament and you with us
some impressions for local girls
Well I really like this club that's all
they only do arrogant ones, especially for
girls
otherwise they are a helicopter special attention
this is women's chess to
found new players everything is cool
it was really great. Huge
thank you for coming and sharing yours
showed us interesting options with her thoughts
and I wish you good luck in the next rounds
Come visit us again Thank you we will be back
literally in a few seconds
now elmiraskripsinka will return to me
at this time we are looking at the last
the party that remained
We still have Valentina in the tournament
Kunina is trying to find some chances
in fact, in both, participant 5
there is very little time left and more
no additions except 30 seconds
will
[music]
also 5 to 6
and that is, she didn’t even want to with the pace
take the king 5 what did it change in
basically as if I
yes, that is, you mean the king here
Let's see 4
that is, she took it to G5 but
Strange
what happens so that it doesn't matter 5
in any case you have to take it as it were
she kicked out here
it’s just that Irina actually planned to
I'll tell you this idea
she made up her mind
to the last one
Oh, now at least I wouldn’t lose
black ones are possible somewhere
Let's show this moment if the king is
6 with a threat I don’t know the nightingale just left
already four let's make more than 4 Yes you go
five and of course and the pawn itself
Wait, no wait G3 Well, you're walking
take no then the same cracker
threatens to universalize
but in fact not Well, somehow it’s already here
after all, the logic of the king is six draws
They’ll do it. That is, I’ll still give it to you. Yes.
latest
strength
but you will still probably lose
black position Well, I don’t want to, but
it won’t work, well, that’s why I like it
move
now the king is seven kuni at 5:00 probably
Yes
six
[music]
no they took Yes to G5
what's happening
[music]
and wings with seeds so Lion King 6 A
maybe she just wants to give away the pawn
with the idea E6 E7 cunnilingus in 5 seconds to 4 then
yes So let's see now
now Come on The Lion King 6 7
Where should everyone go now?
better Yes, to preserve the possibility
shahmala 6
But in other way
they will play if maybe not
need to
against knight Yes
they are actually going towards this I think
that Valya is just waiting for the Russian
TV viewers wake up and finally
look at the ending no wait what
is happening
[music]
what's happening now
let's hit Well, I'm basically here for this
what to do king in short
[music]
maybe Don't don't know maybe
somehow you can’t give it away, but they are basically
have already arrived at this position in my opinion Yes no
in 5 Kings everything
came
she may have decided not to give this one away
pawn
Yes Irina thinks
Well, you know, in such a critical
at the party stage it's actually not like that
I'm just thinking, but maybe a yawn
completely on my nerves
[music]
Well of course 5 you mean it
wait king E6 King and 6 king is 7
And yes, the horse controls D3 cunnilingus in 4 to
good now
What if the king
Wait, let me see how it was
played in the park I no longer have time to follow
Now on our diagram there is a portal
now if black goes D3 that is
yeah basically
Wait wait wait
eight I thought if the king was G6
[music]
shorter than g8
then there is such a horse not in 5 or 8 Yes I
I thought maybe this doesn’t really help
I wanted
to give, that is, with two horses on
in fact, Irina then chose
the simplest way uh yes to do
nothing because there was no need to play with
knight versus rook because I think that
it's over so far
especially after Wait wait
Valentina didn't go until 3 she went King
Leo five I think it's over now
the consignment
four is played
And this is how I think it will end in
due to the fact that the king is active
king squared yes then
actually shorter than five
wants to continue the torment doesn’t want to leave
finish at eight
even at 30 seconds this is basically
enough
In fact
I even watched the games myself
I just admired it
video recording by cameras also allows
still follow your emotions as much as possible
Rarely in chess tournaments such a video
dispositive principle exists which
allows us to monitor our emotions
in cycles and literally in seconds
that moment already Irina looked at
Bali apparently In the sense that somehow
will offer nothing continues to play
That's why
opponent is looking for a mistake
this is soon I think on the trail of the agreement
hands but basically
big disappointment disappointment
of course great I think for Valentine Well
what to do is chess she could be
in principle, well, this option is easy
can slip slip from our
attention these two are not the easiest
option in principle Pay attention
now on the screen results today what
what happened
actually just crazy fighting
complications in every batch
[music]
Yes, there were complications and the struggle was very
there were many tactical options to blunder
in fact it was at every turn even
examples of Alexandra Kosteniuk's games
against Anna Zatonskikh and he talks about
in many ways
position after the second round
four participants
and then we have a participant whose
one point Yes, now there are three white ones and
Nashvili caught up with Khairika and Marie
seabag
at night gnidze he zatonskih on the shelf and
closes
table
Elizabethsu who unexpectedly 0 out of two
and she played rather unsuccessfully in
basically Kanza tournaments when she
finished literally a week before the start
this tournament maybe she is very
I'm tired, it's a little shaky, it's like oh
also self-confidence I hope so
Yes
recovery is easy and
maybe tomorrow it will be white after all
Soviet chess school
again just as simple nothing about it
you won't make it to the tournament
[music]
how to trust yourself that something will happen
the problem will be that when
you're starting on a bit of a bad start
tournament everyone is already sitting and thinking Yeah
now I'm here, I'm waiting for you
I use I know very well that
this is what happens in the grand prix Yes, I was there
Elizabeth Thermal Power Plant didn’t work for me at all
game and everyone wanted to beat me when
this may need to play into your hands
It’s like you’re expecting everyone to be on you
pounce And again you can
This is your chance to return to tournaments with
on the other hand Yes, of course it is not necessary
to be sad and to be like this
boy for child girl for children then
no one really wants to eat Well then
I think I had it again
very interesting day full of more
interesting party As always
a lot of events Yes, thanks to our
girls
as usual makes us very interesting
struggle I think
Valentina Gunina missed my chance
the only such moment
the most dramatic party she could have
Of course, I already have to win this game
the only personal leader in this tournament but
what to do before missed opportunity but
maybe she was just maybe
the only thank you, of course, to ours too
viewers and for questions for support and
fans so
very supportive for your kindness and of course
We are waiting for you tomorrow live 1250
local time may be different
I don’t know how to call you anymore, lovely
him
[music]